WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THIS IS TUESDAY JUNE
FOURTH WE ARE A LITTLE BIT SHY
OF A QUORUM.
BUT WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE A COUPLE OF
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT MR OBERNOLTE
WILL NOT BE HERE TODAY.
MR KILEY IS BEING REPLACED BY MR
FONG.
AND THEN ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB
SIX THIRTY HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM
THE CONSENT AGENDA SO WE WILL
HEAR THAT ITEM [inaudible]
SEEING.
AUTHORS HERE WE HAVE A NUMBER
SIGN IN BUT IN ORDER SENATOR
HERTZBERG WE'LL START WITH.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
FORTY ONE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
MORNING.
YOU KNOW WE ALL OF INTRODUCED
BILLS FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
AND I'M INTRODUCED IN THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE CURRENT STATE OF THE
LAW WITH RESPECT.
TO EQUITY IN CIVIL A DAMAGE
AWARDS IS NOTHING LESS THAN THE
GREGIS. FOR ME TO STORY. TWO
YEARS AGO THE WASHINGTON POST
RAN A STORY THE FOUR YEAR OLD
BOY.
A FOUR YEAR OLD BOY IN BROOKLYN
WAS SUFFERING SEVERE
NEUROLOGICAL DAMAGE AFTER LIVING
IN AN APARTMENT THAT WAS
ILLEGALLY CODE WOULD LEAD PAINT.
BOYS PARENTS SUE THE LANDLORD.
AND IN THAT LITIGATION THE
ATTORNEYS REPRESENTING THE BOY
ESTIMATED THE SHOULD BE AWARDED
THREE MILLION FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THAT WAS THE ESTIMATE.
THE AMOUNT HE WOULD HAVE EARNED
OVER HIS LIFETIME.
WITHOUT THE INJURY.
BUT THE LANDLORDS DEFENSE TEAM
AND THIS ACTUALLY IS A STATE OF
THE LAW THE LANDLORDS DEFENSE
TEAM CHARACTER THE BOYS DAMAGE
AWARD TO BE LESS THAN HALF.
AT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WHY YOU MIGHT ASK.
THE LANDLORDS ATTORNEY ARGUED
THAT BECAUSE THE BOY WAS NOT THE
NO.
HE WAS UNLIKELY TO ATTAIN
ADVANCED EDUCATION THAT WOULD
GARNER THE LARGER INCOME THAT
THE DEFENSE ESTIMATED HE COULD.
THE CASE IS JUST ONE OF MANY
CASES THROUGHOUT OUR SYSTEM OF
JUSTICE IF YOU COULD CALL IT
THAT.
THAT IS AN CITY IS IN A
WIDESPREAD PRACTICE.
IN THESE CASES JUDGES AND JURIES
REALIZE WE'VE COME TO KNOW ON
CALCULATION TABLES CALCULATION
TABLES FROM FRENCH ECONOMIST AND
I HAVE A VERY BRILLIANT FORENSIC
ECONOMIST RIGHT HERE.
THAT ARE USED TO PREDICT
PLAINTIFFS LOST EARNINGS WAGES
ON THE BASIS OF A MEMBERSHIP IN
A PROTECTED CLASS.
SUCH AS RACE OR GENDER.
BECAUSE HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED GROUPS SUCH AS
AFRICAN AMERICANS WOMEN LATINOS
EARN LESS ON AVERAGE IN THEIR
WHITE MALE COUNTERPARTS FOR
EXAMPLE DAMAGES CAN RECEIVE CAN
BE SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER -- THIS
PRACTICE AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE IF
YOU BEGIN TO THINK ABOUT IT RATE
RESULTS PERPETUATE SYSTEMIC
INEQUITY.
A DISPROPORTIONATE AFFECTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR -- AND IS
BASICALLY IF YOU LOOKED UP THE
DEFINITION OF UNFAIR IN THE
DICTIONARY YOU WOULD SEE THIS
RIGHT THERE.
AND SO WITH ME TODAY IS ROBERT
JOHNSON A LEADING FORENSIC
ECONOMIST WHO HAS BEEN ILL TELL
USED VERY IMPRESSIVE STORY SEEN
THIS PLAY OUT IN COURT ROOM
AFTER COURT ROOM FIRSTHAND.
AND DEBBIE CHIANG WITH THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
ALTERED OVER TO MR JOHNSON.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH US PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY.
HI ROBERT W. JOHNSON A THIRTY
EIGHT YEAR CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
WITH AN MBA FROM STANFORD
UNIVERSITY [inaudible]
BY.
THANK YOU BY PROFESSION I'M A
FORENSIC ECONOMIST.
WHO SPECIALIZES IN CALCULATING
DAMAGES IN CIVIL LITIGATION?
BUY A QUALIFIED NEW TESTIFIED IN
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALL FOR FEDERAL DISTRICTS.
IN CALIFORNIA FORTY STATES IN
TWO U. S. TERRITORIES.
I AM A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF FORENSIC
ECONOMISTS FIVE EVALUATED
THOUSANDS OF PERSONAL INJURY AND
WRONGFUL DEATH CASES.
OVER THE PAST THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
SENATE BILL FORTY ONE BECAUSE
IT'S INTENT IS TO STOP THE USE
OF RACE GENDER AND ETHNICITY
METRICS.
THAT REDUCE EARNINGS CAPACITY OF
INJURED PEOPLE IN CIVIL
LITIGATION.
MO OVER SENATE BILL FORTY ONE
WILL ACCOMPLISH THIS WITH OUT
REDUCING THE EARNINGS CAPACITY
OF ANY OTHER RACIAL GENDER OR
ETHNIC GROUP OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO.
I WAS A FORENSIC ECONOMIST.
IN A TRIAL REGARDING THE
WRONGFUL DEATH OF AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN COLLEGE STUDENTS.
MY TASK WAS TO CALCULATE.
THE LOST FUTURE EARNINGS
CAPACITY USING THE U. S.
GOVERNMENT EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT TABLES.
DURING MY CROSS EXAMINATION THE
DEFENSE ATTORNEY ASKS ME DID YOU
WOULD JUST WITH THE FACT.
THAT THE YOUNG MAN WAS BLACK I
SAID YES.
HE LOOKED AT ME AND HE SAID BUT
YOU USE THE EARNINGS OF A WHITE
MALE.
I SAID I DIDN'T HAVE ANY CHOICE.%
I EXPLAINED THAT THE US
GOVERNMENT EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT TABLES.
INCLUDE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
SIXTY FIVE BUT IF YOU'RE SIXTY
FIVE AT THAT TIME.
THAT MEANT YOU STARTED IN THE
WORK FORCE IN THE LEAD EARLY
NINETEEN FIFTIES WHICH IS BEFORE
BROWN VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION.
BEFORE THE NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
EQUAL PAY ACT WE YOU FINISH IS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY WHERE
YOU START.
I DON'T KNOW OF A SINGLE
ECONOMIST IN MY THIRTY FIVE
YEARS WHO'S EVER STATED THAT
WOMEN AND MINORITIES WERE NOT
SUBJECT TO DISCRIMINATION.
IN HIRING PAY AND PROMOTION THE
ONLY DATA SAID THAT DID NOT
EXPERIENCE THAT WOULD BE MY
WHITE MALES A CONDOM IS MUST.
USE AND ASSUME THAT FUTURE
EMPLOYERS.
WILL FOLLOW THE LAW AND NOT
DISCRIMINATE WE PAY COURT
REPORTERS THE SAME WITH A POSTAL
WORKERS THE SAME.
BLACK WHITE MALE TO FEMALE I
TURNED TO DEFENSE COUNSEL AND
SAID.
YOU PUT IN THE SAME RIGHT YEAH
SURE NOT A PROBLEM.
THE WAS NOT AN ISSUE FOR ME
THERE WAS NOT AN ISSUE FOR THE
JURY.
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA WOMEN AND
MINORITIES CONSTITUTE OVER 70%.
OF THE POPULATION OVER 60% OF
OUR HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE
GRADUATES IF THEY GET INJURED
THEY YOU WILL BE SHORT CHANGE.
THE COURSE THE COURSE THE TO THE
CAUSE OF THIS SHORT CHANGE IS
THE USE BY 92% OF THE FORENSIC
ECONOMIST.
IN THE COUNTRY.
IN CIVIL LITIGATION THEY USE
GENDER RACE AND ETHNICITY BASED
EARNINGS TABLES THESE TABLES
PRESERVE.
AND REINFORCE HISTORIC WORKPLACE
DISCRIMINATION AND FAIL TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE PROGRESS WE HAVE
MADE AS A NATION.
LET ME JUST TELL YOU A COUPLE OF
THE CASES THAT I'VE WORKED ON I
DO NEED TO WRAP.
I I NEED YOU TO WRAP UP OKAY
FINE.
MY FINAL ASSESSMENT WOULD BE.
IF YOU LOOK AT A CASE INVOLVING
AN EIGHT DAY -- AT NOT A CALLS A
MEDICAL SCHOOL GRADUATE.
OR A J. D. GRADUATE WHICH WE
CALL IN THE ECONOMIC FIELD
PROFESSIONAL THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A MALE.
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN FEMALE.
LIFETIME EARNINGS TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION IF HE IS A WHITE
FEMALE IT'S ONLY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN DEFICIT.
SENATE BILL FORTY ONE WILL
ELIMINATE THIS TYPE OF THIS.
DEFICIT.
THANK YOU SO WHAT CAN AS WE HAVE
A QUORUM IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE HERE GALLAGHER.
CHAO HERE TO GONZALEZ
[inaudible]
HOLDEN KALRA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS.
REYES.
RIGHT SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM AND
SENATOR THERE ARE AMENDMENTS A
TO ME OR TAKING THE AMENDMENT
ACCEPTANCE ON THE AMENDMENTS
WHICH REMOVE OPPOSITION UNTIL
THE BILL'S APPLICATION TO ONLY
CLASSES AFFECTED BY THE
PRACTICES QUESTION.
THE BILL.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THAT'S WHAT THIS PLACE --
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS DEBORAH
CHIANG I'M -- TRIAL ATTORNEY
WITH MANAGING AND BOILED LOS
ANGELES I'M ALSO THE FIRST VICE
PRESIDENT WITH THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
I WANTED TO NOTE AS THE WOMAN
THAT LAST YEAR WAS DUBBED THE
YEAR OF THE WOMAN BECAUSE OF
MOVEMENTS LIKE TIME IS UP THAT
SOUGHT GENDER APPARENTLY FOR PAY.
YET AT THE SAME TIME IN COURT
HOUSES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WHENEVER THERE WAS A WOMAN OR A
PERSON OF COLOR WHO WAS A
PLAINTIVE.
JURORS WERE ASKED TO LOOK AT
TABLES BASED ON FLAWED.
HISTORICAL DATA BASED ON DECADES
OF PRESUMPTION THAT WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR WOULD NOT
ACHIEVE THE SAME EDUCATIONAL
LEVELS OF WHITE MALE.
A FACT THAT I THINK MISTER
JOHNSON NIGHT TODAY HAVE SHOWN
AGAINST.
THAT THOSE DECADES OF
PRESUMPTION HOWEVER IF EITHER
MISTER JOHNSON -- I WORE IN A
PLAINTIFF TODAY.
CHARTS WOULD BE PROVIDED IN OUR
CASES THAT COULD IN EFFECT BE
BASED ON FLAWED DATA.
AND SO.
WE HAVE CASES IN WHICH WE ASK
OUR EXPERTS TO PROJECT INTO THE
FUTURE SOMETIMES TWENTY YEARS
THIRTY YEARS FORTY YEARS AND
FIFTY YEARS.
EVERYONE OF THOSE HERE SOCIETY
GETS TO BE MORE PROGRESSED WE
HAVE LIFE CARE PLANS NOW FOR
CHILDREN OR FOR YOUNGER ADULTS
WHO WERE FROZEN IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WOULD WOMEN WERE
ONLY MAKING FIFTY CENTS TO EVERY
DOLLAR THAT A MAN WAS MAKING.
AND TO ME LAW SHOULD REFLECT THE
VERY BEST OF SOCIETY OF SOCIETY
TO IMPROVE AND NOTFREEZE US IT
OUT FOR OUR HISTORICAL PAST.
AND I THINK THIS IS WHAT THIS
BILL DOES AND IT FINALLY REMOVED
THE SHACKLES THAT WOMEN AND FOR
NONSENSICAL REASONS THAT
EVERYONE IS CONSIDERED THE SAME
EITHER BASED.
ON THEIR HISTORICAL DATA OF
THEIR OWN -- OCCUPATION OR BASED
ON THEIR EARNING CAPACITY OF THE
HIGHEST AND BEST WHICH WOULD BE
THE WHITE MALE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE.
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT IF YOU
COME FOR GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
RECORD YOUR SHAHAR ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
AARON TAYLOR ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT --
CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE NO POSITION
BUT I JUST DID WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR -- THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THE SPONSORS FOR WORKING
WITH US TO ENSURE WITH THESE --
RECENT AMENDMENTS THAT THERE
WON'T BE ANY AND UNINTENDED
IMPACTS ON OTHER PROTECTED
CLASSIFICATIONS.
THIS RETURN MEMBERS MIKE BELOW
FOR THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AS
INDICATED BY SENATOR HERTZBERG --
SEE JACK IS NOW NEUTRAL WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR IN
REFINING THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SAY NONE OF BRING IT
BACK.
TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OUR SIGNAL SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU FOR MEASURE TIME
ASTRONOMICAL.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE CHAU CHAU AYE CHIU.
DOLLARS.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE FONG.
FONG HI MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
RACING HI.
THANK YOU THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF TRIMMING THE
COMMITTEE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
SENATOR MITCHELL ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB ONE EIGHTY EIGHTH
.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I'M PROUD
TO BE HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHT EIGHT THE
CROWN ACT.
WHICH STANDS FOR TO CREATE A
RESPECTFUL AND OPEN WORKPLACE
FOR NATURAL HAIR.
EURO CENTRIC STAND IF YOU IF YOU
DON'T HAVE LONG TO HELP THE
UNDERPINNINGS OF AMERICAN
CULTURE SINCE THE FOUNDING OF
OUR SOCIETY.
DETERMINING WHAT WAS ACCEPTABLE
AND ATTRACTIVE IN THE MEDIA IN
ACADEMIC SETTINGS AND AT WORK.
FOR CENTURIES BLACK MEN AND
WOMEN DIDN'T OFTEN CHALLENGED OF
STANDARDS WE STRAIGHTENED ARE
HERE WITH HEATER CHEMICAL RELAX
AND A LACK RELAXERS TO MEET
THOSE EURO CENTRIC STANDARDS.
UNTIL TWENTY SIXTEEN A GOOGLE
IMAGE SEARCH FOR THE TERM
UNPROFESSIONAL HAIRSTYLES
YIELDED ONLY PICTURES OF BLACK
WOMEN WITH NATURAL HAIR OR
WEARING BRAIDS -- TWISTS.
ALTHOUGH THIS HARDING THE FACT
WAS NOT PARTICULARLY SURPRISING.
AND SO MEMBERS THE PURPOSE OF
THIS MEASURES TWO FOLD FIRST
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE GREAT NEED
TO EDUCATE THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
ABOUT THE UNIQUE QUALITIES OF
BLACK HAIR TEXTURE AND HOW THEY
RELATE. TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WHERE HE NATURAL HAIR STYLES AS
WELL AS THE EXPERIENCES OF BLACK
PEOPLE.
SECONDLY IT'S DUE TIME TO
CHALLENGE THE COMMONLY HELD
MYTHS AND MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT
WHAT DETERMINES PROFESSIONAL
HAIR IN THE WORKPLACE IN SCHOOLS.
AND EVEN THE MILITARY. FOR YEARS
THERE BEEN TOO MANY CASES OF
BLACK EMPLOYEES AND APPLICANTS
DENIED EMPLOYMENT OR PROMOTION
AND EVEN IN EVEN TERMINATED.
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEY CHOSE TO
WEAR THEIR HAIR.
STUDENTS SENT HOME FROM SCHOOL
BASED ON POLICIES THAT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST YOUNG BLACK
GIRLS AND BOYS WHOSE PARENTS
HAVE CHOSEN TO LOCK THEIR HEAR
MORE BRAVE THEY'RE HERE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GROOMED HAIR
STYLES LIKE MY LOCKS WHICH WOULD
WITHOUT QUESTION FIT AN IMAGE OF
PROFESSIONALISM.
IF BIAS OR NEGATIVE STEREO TYPES
WERE NOT INVOLVED.
SPECIFICALLY SB ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
FOR TEXAS RIGHT BY CLEAR FLYING
IN THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT AND THE EDUCATION
QUOTE.
THAT THE DEFINITION OF RACE IS
INCLUSIVE OF TRAITS HISTORICALLY
ASSOCIATED WITH REYES.
I EAT HERE TEXTURE INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO HAIR TEXTURE AND
NATURAL OR PROTECTIVE HAIRSTYLES.
THIS BILL DOES NOT SUPERSEDE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE
REGULATIONS OR PREVENT EMPLOYERS
FROM ENFORCING REASONABLE
GROOMING STANDARDS THAT RELATE
TO A BONAFIDE JOB QUALIFICATION.
THE CROWN ACT HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTE.
WITH ME HERE TODAY I'M PROUD TO
HAVE WON THE GREEN WAS A
VISITING PROFESSOR AT WASHINGTON
AND LEE UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW
WHERE SHE SERVES AS THE FRANCIS
LEWIS SCHOLAR IN RESIDENCE.
MISS GREENE IS THE LEADING
EXPERT ON HERE DISCRIMINATION
CASES AND WAS QUOTED IN THE EOC
VERSUS CMS COURT OPINION.
ALSO WITH US HERE TODAY IS A Q.
A HATCHET PAUL WHO IS A LICENSED
COSMETOLOGIST ANALOG TITIAN'S
SHE OWNS A SALON HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
CALLED SACRED GROUND SALON THEY
WILL BUT MISS HAVE TO FALL WILL
SPEAK ON THE INTRICACIES AND
PROCESS OF NATURAL HAIR STYLES
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE LOW.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
OKAY GOOD MORNING CHAIR IN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS WENDY GREEN
AND AS THE SENATOR POINTED OUT
I'M A LEADING ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAW PROFESSOR AND
ADVOCATE I GRADUATED FROM XAVIER
UNIVERSITY OF LOUISIANA NEW
ORLEANS WITH HONORS IN ENGLISH
AND A DOUBLE MINOR.
IN AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDIES IN
SPANISH I ALSO EARNED BY JURIS
DOCTORATE FROM TULANE UNIVERSITY
SCHOOL OF LAW ALSO IN NEW
ORLEANS AND A MASTERS OF LIVE
FROM THE GEORGE WASHINGTON
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW.
WHERE SPECIALIZED COMPARED OF
SLAVERY AND RACE RELATIONS LAW
AS WELL AS EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION LAW MY LEGAL
PUBLICATIONS HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN CREATING CIVIL
RIGHTS PROTECTIONS AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION AND WORKPLACES
PUBLIC ACCOMMODATIONS? EIGHT IN
SCHOOLS INCLUDING THE NEW YORK
CITY COMMISSION ONHUMAN RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT GUIDANCE WHICH
CLARIFIES LIKE THE CROWN ACT
NATURAL HERE DISCRIMINATION
CONSTITUTES UNLAWFUL RACE
DISCRIMINATION.
ACCORDINGLY I'VE SPENT MUCH OF
MY PROFESSIONAL CAREER n
LEGAL ACADEMIC INCREASING
AWARENESS AROUND THE HARMS OF
UNCHECKED DISCRIMINATORY
GROOMING POLICIES.
MAYBE POLICIES THAT DID A GREAT%
NATURAL HAIR STYLES AS EXTREME
EXCESSIVE DISTRACTING AND KEPT
POLICIES THAT REQUIRE AFRICAN
SENTENCE TO CUT OFF THEIR HERE
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE WAY IT
NATURALLY GROWS OUT OF THEIR
HEADS.
OR IN THE CASE OF AFRICAN
DESCENT IT WOMEN AND GIRLS
GROOMING POLICIES THAT REQUIRE
THAT THEY DON STREET HERE
USUALLY ACHIEVE THE TOXIC
CHEMICALS EXTREME HEAT STYLING
WIGS AND WEAVES.
WHICH ARE EXPENSIVE AND TIME
CONSUMING TO MAINTAIN THE TO OPT
TO RESULT IN PAINFUL CHEMICAL
BURNS HAIR AND SCALP DAMAGE AS
WELL AS HAIR LOSS RESEARCH ALSO
INDICATES POTENTIAL CORRELATIONS
BETWEEN HAIR STRAIGHTENING
PRODUCTS THAT BLACK WOMEN
FREQUENTLY USE.
IN THEIR INCREASE CHANCES OF
DEVELOPING UTERINE FIBROIDS
FORMER CORPSMAN RELATED
INFERTILITY AND MORE AGGRESSIVE
FORMS OF BREAST AND UTERINE
CANCER.
SIMILARLY STUDIES INDICATE A
POSSIBLE LINKAGE BETWEEN
CHEMICAL RELAX AND AN INCREASED
HORMONAL ACTIVITY.
ACTIVITY AMONG AFRICAN THE
SENATE GIRLS THEREFORE NATURAL
HERE BE AND SLEEP AFRICAN
DESCENT IT WOMEN AND GIRLS IN A
PRECARIOUS CATCH TWENTY TWO
EITHER DON YOUR NATURAL HAIR AT
THE RISK OF LOSS BELIEVE.
BEING DEPRIVED AND EMPLOYMENT IN
ORDER EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY OR
DON STRAIGHT HAIR AT THE RISK OF
AN DURING CONSEQUENTIAL HARMS TO
YOUR PSYCHOLOGICAL PHYSICAL
ANIMAL NO WELL BEING.
MY SCHOLARSHIP IN ADVOCACY HAVE
CRITIQUE FEDERAL COURT DECISIONS
WHICH SANCTION THIS CATCH TWENTY
TWO BY FAILING TO TREAT NATURAL
HERE BE AS AS RACE
DISCRIMINATION.
THIS STATE OF AFFAIRS IS LARGELY
DUE TO AN OUTDATED TRADITIONALLY
CREATE ROLE KNOWN AS THEY
MUTABILITY DOCTRINE WHICH I CAN
DISCUSS IN Q. AND A IF NEEDED.
BUT MOST NOTABLY FEDERAL COURTS
STRICT APPLICATION OF THE
MUTABILITY DOCTRINE HAS PRODUCED
HAIR SPLITTING DISTINCTIONS IF
FOR EXAMPLE AN EMPLOYER DENIES
AN AFRICAN THE SENATE A JOB
BECAUSE SHE TO ADORN THE AFRO.
THE EMPLOYER ENGAGES AN UNLAWFUL
RACE DISCRIMINATION HOWEVER THE
MOMENT SHE TWIST LOCKS OR BRAIDS
THAT AFRO HER HAIR.
IT SEVERS ADVERSE TREATMENT ON
GROUNDS ON THESE GROUNDS THE
EMPLOYERS DISCRIMINATION IS
DEEMED LAWFUL.
THE CROWN ACT FEELS THIS A
JUSTIFIABLE GAP IN STATUTORY
PROTECTION FOR WORKERS AND
STUDENTS WHO SUFFER NATURAL HAIR
DISCRIMINATION ASSISTED MAKE
FORM OF RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
THAT HARKENS BACK TO AREAS OF
RACIAL SLAVERY.
AND RACIAL APARTHEID IN THIS
COUNTRY BASED UPON CALIFORNIA'S
UNIQUE ROLE AS A NATIONAL LEADER
IN ADVANCING EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL THERE TRULY IS NO BETTER
STATE TO NOT ONLY HAVE THIS
TIMELY DIALOGUE ON NATURAL HERE
DISCRIMINATION AND WORKPLACES
AND SCHOOLS.
BUT ALSO TAKE MEANINGFUL ACTION
TOWARD CORRECTING THIS
INEQUALITY UNDER THE LAW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SPLITTING DECISIONS.
I GOT THE THAT'S GOOD USE THAT.
AND YOU DON'T EVEN CRAPPIE DID
THAT SMOOTHLY.
I ONLY BRING THE BEST BEFORE
YOU'RE.
ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY GET IF IF IF YOU
COULD ONLY BRING SOME EXAMPLES
OF ON PROFESSIONAL HAIR STYLING
SO THAT WE COULD SEE COULD YOU
BRING SOME EXAMPLES OF
UNPROFESSIONAL I DON'T KNOW THAT
IT'S NOT MY JOB TO DO I WOULD
ONLY BE BEFORE YOU PROFESSIONAL
EXAMPLE.
OKAY SO I NOTICE [inaudible]
PLEASE.
I GOOD MORNING TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS A KILLER WE
MONNA HATCHET FALL AND I AM.
A COSMETOLOGIST AND ALSO A
PERSON IS DONE NATURAL HAIR FOR
THIRTY TWO YEARS.
I ALSO HAVE A BACKGROUND IN PAN
AFRICAN STUDIES AND I'VE SERVE A
COMMUNITY AND OUR COMMUNITY AS A
BECAUSE AS A COMMUNITY ACTIVIST
ALSO.
AND HAVE OVER -- THREE HUNDRED
CLIENTS SO. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'D LIKE TO ADD -- TO IS
ALSO THAT.
FROM THE BEGINNING BEFORE
COLONIZATION BEFORE WE EVEN CAME
TO THIS COUNTRY AFRICAN PEOPLE
HAVE ALWAYS HAD.
THEIR HAIR AS A CROWN OF GLORY
AS AS A A POINT OF OF JUST
KNOWING WHO THEY ARE -- IT IS
NOT JUST EVER BEEN A HAIRSTYLE
FOR US IT'S ALWAYS THE NOTED
THINGS LIKE OUR TRIBE OR CLAN IS
DENOTED OUR MARITAL STATUS ARE
ECONOMIC STATUS.
IT DENOTES EVERYTHING FOR US IT
TRULY IS OF THE FIRST THING THAT
YOU LOOK AT YOU CAN TELL WHAT A
POOR PERSON IS THAT WHEN THEY
LOOK AT THEIR HAIR.
SO TO HAVE TO SUBSCRIBE ANDBE
MARGINALIZED TO EURO CENTRIC
WHITES OF FROM THE STANDARDS OF
BEAUTY IS NOT ONLY IT LIKE --
LIKE -- SISTER.
WENDY SAID -- IS NOT JUST A
HARMFUL TO A PSYCHOLOGICALLY
PHYSICALLY MENTALLY -- BUT IT OF
THE ALSO IS JUST A DAMPENING OF
YOUR SPIRIT TO NOT BE ABLE TO
PUT 1100% FOR THE WHO YOU ARE.
AS A PERSON -- AND ALWAYS HAVE
TO BE WORRIED ABOUT WHO YOU ARE
WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE IT'S JUST NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD EVER
HAVE TO BE SUBJECTED TO ALTHOUGH
WE HAVE BEEN FOR FOUR HUNDRED
YEARS.
SO I ASK THAT YOU ALSO PASS THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO EACH OF US.
FOURTH OUR BEST EFFORT IS WHO WE
ARE AND AS AFRICAN PEOPLE OUR
CROWN OF GLORY IS OUR CROWN OF
GLORY AND WE DESERVE TO BE ABLE
TO BE WHO WE ARE.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IF YOU GIVE US
YOUR NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION
PLACE OF MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LAND TRITON REPRESENTING
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THERESA TAYLOR
CARROLL AND A MEMBER OF ALPHA
KAPPA ALPHA SORORITY
INCORPORATED NATIONALLY AND
STATE WIDE WE CONSIST OF
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS WITH MANY
DIFFERENT HAIR STYLES AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AT THIS BILL.
LEAH BARRELS ON BEHALF OF THE
CROWN COALITION THE CROWN
COALITION IS A NATIONAL LINE
IT'S THAT IS COMPRISED OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY URBAN LEAGUE COLOR OF
CHANGE IN DATA OF THIS COALITION
WAS CONVENE.
TO TO ADDRESS ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LEGISLATION
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE ARE PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR SB ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT TODAY AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YES HARM TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PLUMMET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN THANK YOU.
I'M IS WORKING ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
CORDY MAKE ANY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MANUALLY ON BEHALF
OF PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS RESPONSIBLE CHIU INSTRUCTS
SUPPORT.
PERSONAL GET US ON BEHALF OF
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT.
VALERIE WILLIAMS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA IRVINE
PARTNERSHIP IN STONG SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
WE NEED TO PUT IT WELL ON BEHALF
OF THE QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING US OF BRAMBLE HERE
RISING ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND EDUCATORS
IN.
CALIFORNIA THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MISTER KALRA.
SOME RESTAURANTS THANK YOU I
REALLY REALLY LIKE A SPELL AND I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT -- BUT
BUILT PROFESSOR THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME. TO BE WITH US
LIMóN US BOTH OF THE LEGAL.
AS WELL AS HISTORICAL.
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL AND ONE
THING I HAD HEARD IT WAS MAKING
ITS WITH THE SENATE AND I DIDN'T
REALIZE UNTIL I WAS -- FOR THE
THE HEARING THIS ONE THAT IT WAS
ALSO MINTED EDUCATION CODE WHICH
IS SO CRITICAL BECAUSE AS WE ALL
KNOW THOSE.
THAT INTERNALIZED.
SELF IMPOSED NEGATIVE NEGATIVE.
OF THOUGHTS OF ONESELF START AT
A VERY YOUNG AGE AND THE FACT
THAT THAT THIS IS.
GOING TO IMPACT -- IN A POSITIVE
WAY MANY IN MANY MANY.
THOUSANDS OF A YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THE STATE MAKE CAN BE PROUD OF
WHO THEY ARE -- I THINK WILL
REALLY SET THEM ON A POSITIVE
PATTERNS AND SO OF THEM VERY
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT THIS BILL
ON THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT MISTER KALRA
IF I JUST MIGHT ADD YOU KNOW
THERE'S A AT SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO WHO HAS
A DAUGHTER.
WHO HAS EXPERIENCE BULLYING --
BECAUSE OF HER MOTHER'S CHOICE
TO ALLOW HER TO WEAR HER HERE
NATURAL SHE'S VERY YOUNG FIFTY
SEVEN YEARS ALL ON HER MOTHER
BROUGHT IT TO THE CAPITAL TO
MEET ME -- TO SEE A PROFESSIONAL
WOMAN WHO -- FOR ALL OF MY
ELECTED LIFE IS CHOSEN TO WEAR
MY HAIR IN ITS NATURAL STATE AND
SO WE HOPE THAT THROUGH THIS
BILL NOT ONLY WILL BE CHANGE THE
LAW.
BUT THROUGH THE PRESS AND
THROUGH -- WOMEN COMING FORWARD
TO TALK ABOUT OUR EXPERIENCES
ALSO SET EXAMPLE FOR BOTH
MOTHERS TRYING TO MAKE DIFFICULT
CHOICES ON BEHALF OF THE LITTLE
GIRLS -- EVERYONE ALSO SAW THE
IN DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR ALL THE
VIDEO OF THE YOUNG WRESTLER --
WHO WOULDN'T VIOLENTLY ASSAULTED?
BY AN OFFICIAL ALMOND TOLD
EITHER CUT YOUR LOCKS OR LET
YOUR TEAM DOWN AND NOT WRESTLE
THAT WAS MIDWAY THROUGH THAT --
WRESTLING TOURNAMENT HE'D BEEN A
HIGH SCHOOL WRESTLER FOR A TIE
IT TIRE HIGH SCHOOL EXPERIENCE
AND SELL A WE HOPE -- TO PREVENT
ACTIONS LIKE THAT FROM TAKING
PLACE AT LEAST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EVER AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR BEING A VERY
POSITIVE ROLE MODEL FOR HUNDRED
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
[inaudible]
HI.
AND WHAT ELSE.
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE I WOULD
JUST SAY COLLEAGUES THAT IT'S
TWENTY NINETEEN AND FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IN THE LAW.
THAT SANCTIONS THE JOB
DESCRIPTION THAT IMMEDIATELY
EXCLUDES ME FROM A POSITION.
NOT BECAUSE OF MY CAPABILITIES
OR EXPERIENCE BUT BECAUSE OF HOW
I CHOOSE TO WEAR MY HAIR IS LONG
OVERDUE FOR REFORM WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK -- FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE CROWN ACT SENATE
BILL.
ONE EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS COLOR --
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE FONG.
FONG AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE RADIUS
[inaudible]
YES I THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
YOUR ATTENTION.
THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB SIX EIGHTY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI.
MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBERS I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
TECHNICAL MA'AM AND SET OUT AS
OUTLINED ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS AS THE NAILS THE
STATE'S THIS BILL SIMPLY MINOR
EYES.
ALL RIGHTS TO SECTIONS OF THE
CIVIL CODE SOME WHICH SHOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN AN ALTAR SINCE THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. TO REFLECT
TODAY'S REALITIES ON MARRIAGE
AND LAST NAME SOME WITH THAT
ORDER TONIGHT VOTE.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU IS ANYONE IN LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
NO.
IS ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
WAS AND SALAS -- I'M JUST AT I
PROBABLY CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION
THANK TRIED A SIMILAR BILL A FEW
YEARS AGO WHY SO LIMITED I MEAN
THERE ARE.
MADE IN NAME IS USED --
THROUGHOUT OUR GOVERNMENT CODE.
WHY SO LIMITED MEAN OTHER
CHANGES IN THE FAMILY CODE
SECTION JUST EVERYWHERE ENTER
CODE THAT REALIZE QUITE WHY ONLY
THIS SECTION?
MY ON THE RIGHT BILL YEAH THIS
IS ON THE CIVIL CODE SECTION
YEAH YES.
SO THE QUESTION IS WHY DIDN'T
YOU TACKLE THE ENTIRE.
STATUTORY BODY OF I ACTUALLY
JUST I THOUGHT OF IT BEING IN
THE FAMILY CODE IN WHAT WERE YOU
NORMALLY SEE IT I JUST ACTUALLY
NEVER THOUGHT ABOUT IT DURING
THE ENTIRE CODE.
I'M NOT.
I DON'T OPPOSE.
DOING AMENDMENT ON THE FLOOR TO
EXTEND THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
CODE.
IF THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
COMMITTEES [inaudible]
DESIRE.
I WAS THINKING OF FAMILY
PRACTICE WE NORMALLY SEE A OF
IT'S THIS REALLY SAYS WHERE IT
IS BUT WELL I GUESS THE
MINISTRATION TRIED IN THE CODE
AND THEY TOLD ME IT WOULD COST
LIKE FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OR
SOMETHING SO I'D.
WHAT IS FORCING A THIS WAS?
I THINK WE SHOULD UPDATE OUR
CODES IN GENERAL BUT I JUST I
WAS JUST WONDERING IF THERE WAS
A REASON.
I'M NOT ASKING YOU TO TAKE THAT
AMENDMENT AND YEAH WE HAVE TO
FALL INTO A PREP SO.
NO.
NO LET'S GET ONE PIECE AT A TIME
MAYBE IF WE DON'T ONE PIECE AT A
TIME IT WON'T COST ANYTHING.
AND AND THAT WAS PART OF THE
THINKING IS THIS CAME TO THE
COMMITTEE I BIRTH CERTIFICATES
AND AND AND OTHER PIECES WOULD
ACTUALLY ADD QUITE A BIT OF
COSTS WHICH DOES MAKE IT.
A CHALLENGE IN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE -- AS AS WELL AS FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION IN THE CIVIL
CODE IS A CODE THAT WE NORMALLY
GO TO AND THAT THE FAMILY
MATTERS SO.
ALRIGHT I WON'T TAKE A LOOK AT
THE STRETCH YEAH I JUST WANTED
TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE UPDATED
LANGUAGE THROUGHOUT.
OUR CODES THAT'S ALL.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS IS
GALLAGHER.
THOUGH I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR --
YOU KNOW I JUST I REALLY FEEL
LIKE THIS IS A LIKE SOLUTION IN
SEARCH OF A PROBLEM I MEAN I
THINK.
YOUR USE OF MAIDEN NAME MIGHT BE
OLD FASHIONED -- BUT I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS AND IS.
YOU KNOW.
IT'S A SIMPLE WAY OF OF PUT ON
THERE INSTEA CHANGING IT TO NOW
ON THESE FORMS IS GOING TO SAY.
LEGAL NAME BEFORE MARRIAGE OR
LAST NAME BEFORE FIRST MARRIAGE.
IT'S LAST NAME BEFORE FIRST
MARRIAGE AND THE IN A DAY I JUST
DON'T SEE ANYTHING WRONG WITH
CONTINUE HUGHES.
MAY NAME I DON'T SEE THIS HUGE
OUTCRY -- FROM PEOPLE TO CALL
FOR THIS CHANGE IN.
QUITE A SAID SEE WE HAVE A LOT
BIGGER ISSUES TO FACE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE WEATHER THAT WE
NEED TO CHANGE THIS TERM.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
AUTHOR WHO YEAH.
I DO AT LEAST GIVE ONE VOTE TO I
THINK USUALLY DURING THE
LEGISLATURE EXCEPT RIGHT BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE ALL TRIED TO DO A
MORE AMBITIOUS LET'S PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
I'VE DONE IN THE PAST
[inaudible]
THOSE.
I'M SORRY I'M.
I'M THANK YOU FOR GIVE ME THE
COURTESY OF SAME TWICE I WOULD
SAY I THINK IT'S VERY
APPROPRIATE. TO DISSOLVE THE USE
OF A TERM THAT WAS USED -- IN
ORDER TO FIND A VIRGIN WOMAN.
NO LONGER BELONGS IN A CODE IF
WE VIEW WOMEN AS EQUAL SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MIGHT DISAGREE.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS
ABSOLUTELY CAPTAIN APPROPRIATE
YES THERE IS LOTS OF HISTORIC
REFERENCES MANY OF THEM ARE
OUTDATED AND MANY OF THEM ARE
INSULTING AND I THINK IT'S PART
OF OUR JOB TO CLEAN UP THE CODES.
SATURDAY MAY CLOSE I THINK THE A
STAFF REPORT THAT SAID.
FIND JOB OF OUTLINING THE
DESIRABILITY OF HAVING THIS --
MEASURE PUT INTO LAW ENTIRE CHAT
VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
A MEDICAL ROLE PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
THEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE FONG.
FONG AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORTH AYE REYES.
REYES I THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU THAT
TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
THIRTY SENATOR WIENER
[inaudible] FIVE MORNING.
MORNING THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
THANK YOU TO CHAIR INTO A
STAFFER WORKING WITH US IN THE
SPELLING WE'RE HAPPY -- TO
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENT THAT'S
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU.
THE CALL YOU THOUGHT ABOUT BEEN
FREQUENTLY BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE --
ASKING YOU TO PASS LEGISLATION
TO AND DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
LGBT PEOPLE -- TODAY I'M HERE TO
ASK YOU -- TO PASS A BILL THAT
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST OPPOSITE
SEX COUPLES SPECIFICALLY ON OUR
DOMESTIC PARTNER OUT REGISTRY
CURRENTLY -- TO REGISTER AS
DOMESTIC PARTNER YOU CAN --
EITHER BE -- A SAME SEX COUPLE
OR YOU CAN BE AN OPPOSITE SEX
COUPLE IF ONE OF THE PARTNERS IS
AGE SIXTY TWO OR OLDER.
AND THE REASON FOR THIS WAS OF
COURSE -- LGBT PEOPLE COULD NOT
GET MARRIED PREVIOUSLY -- AND SO
WERE GIVEN UP WE WERE -- CREATED
THE MASTER PARTNERSHIP REGISTRY --
AND THEN FOR OLDER OPPOSITE SEX
COUPLES BECAUSE OF SOCIAL
SECURITY ISSUES -- WERE ALSO
GIVEN THE PRIVILEGE OF
REGISTRANTS MASSIVE PARTNERS OF
COURSE NOW UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN
ALL -- GET MARRIED AND WE SHOULD
ALL BE ABLE TO ENTER INTO A
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP AND THIS
DISCRIMINATION REALLY MAKES NO
SENSE AND WE SHOULD GIVE PEOPLE
THE ABILITY -- TO DEFINE THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS AND TO GET MARRIED
IF THEY WANT TO GET MARRIED TO
REGISTER AS DOMESTIC PARTNERS IF
THEY WANT -- TO OR NOT TO DO ANY
OF THAT -- AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHAT WITH ME TODAY IS TAMMY
MARTIN FROM A QUALITY CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA SERVING
THE STATE'S LGBT Q. POPULATION?
AND WE ARE PROUD SUPPORTERS OF
SB THIRTY WHICH REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S RESPECT FOR THE
VALUES AND LONG TERM PLANS OF
ITS DIVERSE POPULATION.
AND PROVIDES GREATER FREEDOM FOR
PEOPLE TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
WHAT IS BEST FOR THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS.
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA LED THE WAY
IN OUR STATE'S QUEST TO ACHIEVE
MARRIAGE EQUALITY FOR SAME SEX
COUPLES.
AND AS PART OF THAT WORK THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
HELD THAT STATE LAWS SHOULDN'T
TREAT PEOPLE DIFFERENTLY BASED
ON SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
THEREFORE CALIFORNIA'S DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIP REGISTRY IS OUTDATED
AND SHOULD NO LONGER BE ONLY
AVAILABLE. TO SAME SEX COUPLES
OR OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES OVER AGE
SIXTY TWO IT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO ALL COUPLES NOT EVERYONE
WISHES TO ENTER INTO MARRIAGE
BUT ALL COUPLES SHOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE RELATIONSHIPS AND
FAMILIES RECOGNIZED AND
PROTECTED.
SB THIRTY HELPS THEM DO THAT FOR
THESE REASONS EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS SB THIRTY
AND RESPECTFULLY URGES THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AS WELL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IF YOU COULD GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE SEC
BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
MEN'S WORKING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAMBERS MATTHEW
CYBERLINK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
ELECTION OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIVER BIRMINGHAM ON BEHALF OF
THE LONG BEACH BAR ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
RIGHT THE NONE OF BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
WITH GALLAGHER.
SOME SENATOR I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY -- BUT
IT DOES BEG THE QUESTION -- DO
WE NEED TO MASTER PARTNERSHIPS
ANYMORE IN CALIFORNIA I MEAN.
THE CIVIL CONCEPT LEGAL CONCEPT
OF MARRIAGE THAT.
THEY WERE ALL CONCERNED WITH
ENCOMPASSES A LOT OF DIFFERENT
RELATIONSHIPS RIGHT.
IT IN INCLUDES YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO HAVE COVETED
COMMITTED.
RELATIONSHIPS AND ALSO PEOPLE
WHO HAVE.
YOU KNOW MAYBE A MORE ABOUT AN
ARRANGEMENT OF CONVENIENCE TYPE
OF OF MERIT RIGHT IT IT.
INCLUDES PEOPLE THAT.
HAVE A RELIGIOUS VIEW OF THEIR
MARRIAGE AND NON RELIGIOUS VIEW
OF THEIR MARRIAGE WE STILL VIEW
THAT AS MARRIAGE LEGALLY -- IT
INCLUDES EVEN PEOPLE WHO -- NO
LONGER LIVE TOGETHER LIVE
COMPLETELY SEPARATE LIVES MAY
WITH OTHER PEOPLE BUT ARE STILL
LEGALLY MARRIED. FOR THE
PURPOSES OF LAW AND SO FOR ALL
OF OUR TAX PURPOSES AND OTHER
PURPOSES ARE STILL.
THE UDA'S MERIT SO I MEAN THE
COMTE THE LEGAL CONCEPT OF
MARRIAGE INCLUDES A LOT OF
DIFFERENT RELATIONSHIPS AS I
THINK IS THE MOTIVATION BEHIND.
YOUR BILL -- SO WHY NOT JUST
HAVE PEOPLE.
IS IT JUST THE WORD MARRIAGE OR
IS IT WHY HAVE THIS KIND OF TWO
DIFFERENT CLASSES.
AND TO BEG THE QUESTION ALSO HAS
THAT IS IT SORT OF A SEPARATE
BUT EQUAL.
DISTINCTION IF WE CONTINUE TO
KEEP.
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS AND
MARRIAGES AS IF THEY'RE KIND OF
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS LEGALLY.
WELL I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
AND I THAT THE BALLOT TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION IT'S ONLY SEPARATE
BUT EQUAL IF PEOPLE ARE FORCED
INTO ONE OR THE OTHER BUT THIS
IS ABOUT TOWARDS.
ON THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS THAT
SHE DID A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
OUTLINING THE VARIOUS.
REASONS EITHER FINANCIAL OR
PHILOSOPHICAL THAT PEOPLE MIGHT
CHOOSE TO BE THE MASTER PARTNERS
INSTEAD OF MARRIAGE -- THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE WHO THEY JUST DON'T
BELIEVE IN THE INSTITUTION OF
MARRIAGE BUT THEY DO WANT TO
HAVE BASIC PROTECTIONS -- IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR FAMILY AND
FOR THEIR CHILDREN -- AND FOR IN
HEARD AND SO ALL OF THOSE.
NEEDS -- THERE ALSO -- POTENTIAL --
TAX IMPLICATIONS OF GETTING
MARRIED AND THERE MIGHT BE SOME
PEOPLE WHO BECAUSE OF COURSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE DOMESTIC PARTNERS AND
VIEWS -- AS STILL BEING SINGLE
AND THERE MIGHT BE COUPLES OUT
BECAUSE OF A FEDERAL TAX ISSUES
MIGHT CHOOSE NOT TO BE MARRIED --
IN ADDITION -- FOR SENIORS THERE
ARE IMPLICATIONS OF BEING
MARRIED OR NOT MARRIED IN TERMS
OF SOCIAL SECURITY WHICH IS WHY --
WE'VE ALWAYS ALLOWED ANYONE
SIXTY TWO AND OLDER -- TO ENTER
INTO THE DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
BECAUSE OF THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ISSUES SO THERE ARE STILL
REASONS ABOUT AGAIN BOTHPHILOSOPHICAL OR FINANCIAL WHY
PEOPLE MIGHT CHOOSE TO DO THIS --
AND SO -- YOU KNOW PEOPLE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE DEBATE --
BUT FOR NOW WE WHEN I APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT WE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE NOT DISCRIMINATING.
OTHER QUESTIONS SECOND WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU AND CENTER THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS ONE OF
THE CONCERNS THAT THAT.
I HAVE THAT PEOPLE SOMETIMES
THINK THAT A DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIP IS.
EASILY MORE EASILY DISSOLVE THAN
AMERICA JUST NOT TRUE SO FOR THE
MYRIAD REASONS YOU'VE GIVEN. ONE
OF THE REASONS WE DON'T WANNA
FACILITATED SUBMITTING -- THIS
IS EASY TO GET OUT OF IT IS A
FORMAL RELATIONSHIP
APPROPRIATELY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
PROJECT IN THE THAT IN ADDITION
BECAUSE SOME OF THE LOCAL
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS -- ARE --
NOT OF THE SAME LEGAL STATURE
PEOPLE GET CONFUSED WHICH IS
ALSO I THINK THE COUNTY CLERK'S
LIKE THAT'S BECAUSE WE'RE NO
LONGER REQUIRING THEM. TO BE THE
ONES TO PROVIDE IT SECRETARY OF
STATE AND SO.
I THINK BURKE HOPEFULLY
RESOLVING SOME OF THE CONFUSION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO THAT YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHOW.
CHOW I CHOOSE.
GONZALEZ.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE FONG.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORTH AYE REYES.
REYES AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
SENATOR DORADO EUROPE NEXT YEAR
OF TWO BILLS SB TWO TWENTY FIVE
IN SB. FOUR NINETY FIVE ITEMS
FOUR AND FIVE ON OUR AGENDA.
GIVE A PREFERENCE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TAKE. FOR TWO TWO FIVE OKAY
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB.
TWO TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- GOOD
MORNING.
YEAH ALL MEMBERS COLLEAGUES --
SB -- TWO TO FIVE REMOVES A VERY
OBSOLETE CODE SECTION WRITTEN IN
THE EIGHTEEN SEVENTIES TO
EXCLUDE IMMIGRANTS FROM.
CIVIL CIVIL PARTICIPATION.
IT ENSURES THAT QUAL ALL
QUALIFIED CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS.
MAY BE APPOINTED TO SERVE ON
CALIFORNIA'S MANY STATE LOCAL
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS TO
REMOVE BARRIERS TO SERVICE AN
AUTHORIZED ALL QUALIFIED.
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS TO SERVE SO
THAT THEIR PERSPECTIVES INVOICES
OR INCLUDED IN DECISION MAKING
ON POLICIES.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO PAY
TAXES TO OUR FEDERAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENT DO NOT HAVE FAIR
REPRESENTATION IN CIVIC MATTERS.
THIS BILL I WANT TO CLARIFY ONLY
APPLIES TO BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THAT ARE NOT
POSITIONS OF EMPLOYMENT.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO OFFER HARD
WORKING PEOPLE WITH DIVERSE
EXPERIENCES A VOICE IN THE STATE
WHERE THEY LIVE AND WORK.
AS A LEGAL MATTER THIS BILL WILL
ALIGN THE STATE'S DEFINITION OF
QUOTE UNQUOTE CITIZEN WITH THE
DEFINITION FOUND IN THE
CITIZENSHIP CLAUSE OF THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT.
PUTTING AN END TO OLD LANGUAGE
MEANT TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
CHINESE IMMIGRANTS.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME KLAUDIA OLD
VIA FROM LOS ANGELES AND BETTER
TO HEAL SENIOR ARE ORGANIZER
WITH CHIRLA. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO TWO FIVE THANK YOU FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I
AM CLIO LIVADIA DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL
SPEAKING IN MY PRIVATE CAPACITY.
I COME FROM A PORTUGUESE FAMILY
WHOSE MOTOR WAS ALWAYS TO RISE
ABOVE OBSTACLES AND RISE TO THE
OCCASION WHERE I WAS TAUGHT THAT
WE HAVE A CIVIC DUTY. TO MAKE A
POSITIVE CHANGE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO CONTINUOUSLY FOR
BY A BATTLE FOR GOOD.
I'VE SPENT THE LAST TWO YEARS
WORKING -- IMPROVING DOWNTOWN
LOS ANGELES BY RESEARCHING A
TECHNOLOGY FOR LAPD.
WHICH IF IMPLEMENTED WILL COULD
INCREASE ITS PRODUCTIVITY BY 85%
AND SAVE THE DEPARTMENT TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
I'VE RAISE AWARENESS FOR THE
NEEDS OF HIS STRUCTURE
REINFORCEMENT OF THE WEEK HERE
NARAL DAM AND THE RETROFITTING
OF SOFT STORY BUILDINGS.
I PRODUCE A JOB FAIR FOR THE
HOMELESS WITH FOUR HUNDRED
ATTENDEES AND FORTY VENDORS
WITHOUT ANY COMPENSATION SIMPLY
TO GIVE BACK. TO A COUNTRY I'VE
LIVED IN FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
I'VE SELFLESSLY DEDICATED MY
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
WITH NO PERSONAL GAME BUT THE
KNOWLEDGE OF A JOB WELL DONE.
MY BODY OF WORK OF SERVITUDE
EARNED ME THE TRUST OF MY
COMMUNITY A LARGE. TO THE EXTENT
OF BEING INSTRUCTED BY THE
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES RABBI. TO
RUN THE BACK END OF THE JEWISH
TEMPLE FOR THE LAST YEAR.
I AM THE HOW ABOUT OFFICE OF ONE
I ALSO PARTICIPATE WITH JUDGE
GREG MITCHELL AND THE SKID ROW
RUNNING CLUB WHICH GIVES
OFFENDERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REPLACE.
OPIOID ADDICTIONS BEFORE RUNNING
PROGRAM.
DURING THE WOMEN'S MONTH I WAS
INVITED TO GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
WOMEN IN LEADERSHIP SERIES UP IN --
TO ENCOURAGE WOMEN SUCH AS
MYSELF TO CONSIDER PARTICIPATING
COMMITTEES TO BRIDGE BRIDGE THE
GENDER GAP.
UNFORTUNATELY AS THE CURRENT LAW
STANDS I DON'T QUALIFY I AM
CAPPED OUT.
WITH SB TWO TWO FIVE MOVING
FORWARD MY LOCAL COLLABORATIVE
EFFORTS COULD BE AMPLIFIED TO
BRING A DIVERSE PERSPECTIVE TO
WHICHEVER COMEDIAN CHOSEN TO
SERVE IN
BY APPROVING THIS BILL YOU WOULD
BE WIDENING THE POOL OF THE
DEDICATED PERSONS.
WHOSE HIGHEST PRIORITY IS OUR
SHARED INTEREST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S PROSPERITY THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BETTER KIANA STATEWIDE ON STATE.
I SEE ORGANIZED I'M SORRY WITH
THE COLLISION FOR ME TO MAKE AN
RIGHTS CHIRLA.
AND I'M HERE FROM SUPPORT SB.
TWO TWO FIVE I'M RESERVOIR
HEIGHTS AND HAVE BEEN LIVING
THERE FOR TEN YEARS NOW.
I WAS BORN IN SHOPPERS MEDICAL
AND MY FAMILY I SELL THE NORTH
THE LOS ANGELES IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE I WAS SIX
YEARS OLD THAT.
MY MOM WAS A SEAMSTRESS AND MY
DAD WAS PACKING BOX OF CLOTHES
THEY'RE WORKING IN A SWEATSHOP
COULD.
LIKE MANY MAKING USE OTHER IN
HIGH SCHOOL THAT WOULD BE
CHALLENGING TO GET MY COLLEGE
EDUCATION GIVEN THAT WE STILL DO
NOT HAVE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WHICH
IS WHEN I WAS GRADUATING.
IN THE SAME YEAR I WITNESS THE
DREAM ACT THE FEDERAL TREATMENT
LEGISLATION FAILING.
AND IT'S AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD.
I REALIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
GETTING INVOLVED OF INVOLVING A
COMMUNITY OF PARTICIPATING
PUBLIC DISCOURSE AND BUILDING
PEOPLE POWER.
I NEEDED GOT INVOLVED CHIRLA AND
THE DOCUMENTS IN CLUB AT MY
UNIVERSITY.
SHORTLY AFTER GRADUATION I BEGAN
WORKING AS A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE
AT CHIRLA. FOR TWO YEARS I WORK
WITH A MAJOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND CREDIT TRANSFORM A
SUMMER INTERNSHIP ACADEMY.
UNDER THE WISE UP YOUTH PROGRAM.
AT SHIRT UP I WENT FROM HIGH
SCHOOL YOUTH ORGANIZER TO
COLLEGE ORGANIZER WHEN I MANAGE
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK.
FOR TWO YEARS AS WELL.
IN ALL DOZENS OF YOUTH IMMIGRANT
LEADERS HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM AND MANY OF THEM HAVE
VISIT YOU ARE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND SACRAMENTO TO ADVOCATE FOR
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND INTEGRATION.
I HAD THE HONOR OF MENTORING A
DOCUMENT STUDENTS TO GO AND
PURSUE THEIR DREAMS.
MANY OF THESE IMMIGRANT YOUTH.
ARE NOW COLLEGE GRADUATES ARE
AND OUR EDUCATORS.
THEY WORK IN LOCAL CITIES THERE
IN COUNTY OFFICES AND SUMMER
LANDING.
LEADING ORGANIZING EFFORTS AT
NON PROPOSITIONS AND THAT UNIONS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BASED UP ON MY EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH HIM AGAIN YOUTH I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THEY ARE
HOPEFUL AND SERVING IN PUBLIC
OFFICE AT VARIOUS LEVELS.
YOU SEE MANY OF THEM AS INTERNS
FELLOWS AND STUFF AND STAFF AT
CITY STATE.
AND IN CONGRESS.
SB TWO TO FIVE WILL HELP YOUNGER
STUDENTS.
IMAGINE THE FUTURE WITHOUT AS
MANY BARRIERS SB TWO TO FIVE
WILL ALLOW IMMIGRANT YOUTH TO
PARTICIPATE IN DEMOCRACY AND
BUILDING OF THEIR COMMUNITIES.
BY VOTING YES ON THIS BILL
YOU'RE VOTING FOR TO FURTHER THE
ACCEPTANCE AND INTEGRATION OF
IMMIGRANTS INTO OUR SOCIETY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE
CHRIS CHRIS RESPONDS WITH YOUR
LOCAL THIS REMAIN IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS PROBABLY A SPONSORED
ANSWERING TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLACE -- RACHEL
WALLACE HERE WITH A SO YOU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MANDY TAYLOR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LGBT Q. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
AT MEDI HIGHER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ANDREY RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT -- CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS WAS GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
SO -- JUST CURIOUS AND WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW MORE -- WHAT WHY
WHY NOT OBTAIN YOUR CITIZENSHIP
I MEAN -- HAVE YOU TRIED TO OR
IS WHAT'S.
WHAT'S KIND OF THE IMPEDIMENT --
BARRIER THERE.
THROUGH THE CHAIR SIR.
SO I THINK IT IS -- IMMIGRATION
VERY COMPLICATED IS VERY CASE BY
CASE -- UNFORTUNATELY -- IT YET
THERE'S A LOT OF BARRIERS
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY TYPE
OF REFORM SINCE EIGHTY SIX SO A
LOT OF FOLKS EVEN THOUGH THEY
MAY BE PRESENT HERE AND THEY
HAVE A WERE THE STORY.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LAWS ON THE
BOOKS AND CASE LAW DOESN'T ALLOW
FOR THEM TO ADJUST THEIR STATUS
AT ANY POINT IN TIME -- AND AND
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES THEY MIGHT
BE ABLE TO BUT EVEN THEN -- I
THINK A LOT OF THE FOLKS OVER
REPRESENT -- HAVE EXHAUSTED ALL
RESOURCES TO TRY TO ADJUST THEIR
STATUS BUT UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE
OF A BROKEN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
BOB UNFORTUNATELY NOTHING AS A
OF TO THEM.
RIGHT.
THE MAGIC DO NOT WANT TO SPEAK
TO THAT'S OKAY IT'S NOT YEAH.
FROM YOU GUYS BUT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO BY LAW.
YEAH OKAY GO AHEAD -- SO I'LL
TRY TO MAKE A REALLY LONG STORY
MEDIUM [inaudible]
I TRY.
IS IT IT'S BEEN ATTORNEY I MOVED
HERE WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN I MOVED
TO MINNESOTA AS AN EXCHANGE
STUDENT.
I LIVED WITH -- A LUTHERAN
FAMILY I CAME FROM.
BEING AN ONLY CHILD MY MY DAD
PASSED AWAY WHEN I WAS.
FIFTEEN AND AT THE SAME TIME I
WAS SUED BY HIS GIRLFRIEND'S FOR
HALF OF MY INHERITANCE.
SHE WAS THREATENING BOB AND SO
MY MOM.
DECIDED TO SEND ME.
TO THE UNITED STATES SO I COULD
GET  DIFFERENT APPLAUSE MORE
POSITIVE EXPERIENCE OF FROM WHAT
I WAS HAVING -- I WENT TO HIGH
SCHOOL IN MINNESOTA WHERE A
LITTLE HOUSE ON THE PRAIRIE IS
THAT THE CITY OF NEW ON A ON TOP
I LATER WENT TO COLLEGE AND I
MATT MY EX HUSBAND.
WE WERE MATT WAS SO.
UP UNTIL I MET HIM I WAS LEGAL.
AND I HAD TO TRANSFER MY STATUS
TO BE SPONSORED UNDER HIM.
AND WE WERE TOGETHER FOR FIVE
YEARS BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE WERE
TOO YOUNG AND WAS MEANT TO BE
[inaudible]
AND I NEVER I'VE NEVER GOT AN
INTERVIEW.
SO TECHNICALLY MY CASE STILL
OPEN.
ANY JUST FELL THROUGH THE CRACKS.
AND IT'S JUST AN IMMIGRATION
FLAW PROBABLY A CLIP CLERICAL
ERROR.
THERE'S NOTHING I CAN DO I DON'T
QUALIFY FOR EINSTEIN VISA.
UNFORTUNATELY.
AND YOU HAVE TO IT IT'S A VERY
TOUGH THERE'S NO EASY.
WAY FOR UP A PERSON.
WHO IS STOP?
TAKING UNDER SOMEONE'S UMBRELLA.
TO HAVE TO FIX IT SO MY ONLY IN.
MY ONLY SOLUTION FROM THIS POINT
FORWARD IS TO GET REMARRIED.
BOB AND I I REFUSED TO DO IT.
IN THE ILLEGAL WAY SO
[inaudible]
IT IS.
UNTIL SOMETHING HAPPENS THAT
WOULD CHANGE. TO FACILITATE IT'S
NOT IMPOSSIBLE BUT THERE NEEDS
TO BE SOME SORT OF REFORM IN
ORDER.
TO I HAVE A FAIR.
NONE.
NONE SOCIAL ECONOMICAL.
BASED SO THAT THAT EMBRACES
EVERYBODY'S SO ANYBODY COULD
HAVE A CHANCE TO TAKE PROPER
STEPS TO GET THERE.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NOT A A
PATHWAY.
I JUST WANNA ADD ONE QUICK THING
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS HAVE AN AVERAGE OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA FOR TEN
YEARS.
SO THEY'RE VERY WELL ESTABLISHED
THERE ALSO -- A MIX THAT IS
FAMILIES ABOUT 70% OF A MORE AND
MAKE STATUS FAMILY SO YOU HAVE A
PARENT.
OF WHOSE UNDOCUMENTED CITIZEN.
OF SPOUSE I MEAN YOU KNOW LEGAL
RESIDENT KIT I MEAN IT'S IT'S
EVERYTHING MIXED UP IN THERE SO
THIS IS A VERY INTEGRATED PART
OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
YOU CANNOT TELL ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER WE LIVE TOGETHER WE WORK
TOGETHER WE GO TO CHURCH
TOGETHER IT'S A VERY VERY MIXED --
A YOU KNOW A PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY SO AS LONG AS THEY'RE
A MIX PART OF OUR COMMUNITY WE
FEEL LIKE.
THEY SHOULD BE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY IN POSITIONS THAT
ARE NOT YOU KNOW ELECTED --
THEY'RE NOT PAID BUT THEY REALLY
WANT TO GIVE TO OUR COMMUNITY
WITH THEIR EXPERIENCE
[inaudible]
SO.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE ANSWERS AND
AND ME I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
HEAR THE HUMAN SIDE.
OF THE STORY HERE AND SO THAT'S
PART OF WHY I WAS.
NOT ASKING THAT AND I AND LET ME
JUST SAY I I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE -- THE MOTIVATION
BEHIND THIS BILL AND I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU. TO THE PEOPLE WHO
TESTIFY HERE'S FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO YOUR COMMUNITY IS VERY
COMMENDABLE IS LAUDABLE --
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE DOING.
GREAT THINGS ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE
IN YOUR COMMUNITIES AND
CERTAINLY.
THAT DOESN'T YOU KNOW -- WHETHER
OR NOT WE CAN DO THAT AND IT
WITH AN OFFICIAL TITLE OR NOT.
ACTUALLY I WOULD ARGUE SOME OF
THE PEOPLE WHO DO THE MOST
WORKING PEOPLE WITHOUT A TITLE
YOU KNOW THAT DON'T HAVE.
A POSITION -- THEY JUST GO OUT
THERE AND DO GREAT THINGS IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND I AND I SEE HIM
EVERY DAY -- SO I'M I'M TRULY
THANKFUL FOR THAT.
I THINK WHERE IT COMES TO FOR ME
ON THIS ISSUE THOUGH IS IT
CITIZENSHIP DOES HAVE TO MEAN
SOMETHING OR OR DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING AT ALL RIGHT AND IN OUR
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT IS SET UP
THAT WE WANT PEOPLE TO BECOME
CITIZENS.
AND THE BENEFIT THAT COMES FROM
BEING A CITIZEN IS.
IS THE FULL PARTICIPATION IN THE
GOVERNMENT IS THE ABILITY TO
VOTE IS THE ABILITY TO RUN FOR
ELECTED OUT TO HOLD OFFICE.
THE WHOLE GOVERNMENTAL OFFICE.
AND AND YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN TO
MANY OF THESE CEREMONIES WHERE
PEOPLE BECOME.
NEW CITIZENS AND IT'S AN AMAZING
THING AND IT'S A AND AND THESE
PEOPLE HAVE GONE THROUGH THAT
PROCESS OF NATURALIZATION.
AND I AM THE FIRST TO AGREE TO
HAVE A BROKEN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM
WE DO AND AND AND M. WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO MAKE THIS.
A SIMPLER PROCESS BUT MULTI
MILLION WANT PEOPLE.
TO COME IN TO CITIZENSHIP LEARN
ABOUT OUR GOVERNMENT.
AN EX AND AND AT THE END THAT
THAT.
THAT PLEDGE THAT HEY I'M
RENOWNED SCENE MY ALLEGIANCE TO
ANOTHER COUNTRY AND NOW I'M I'M.
A CITIZEN OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA RIGHT IN [inaudible]
SO.
I THINK THAT'S THE BIG ISSUE
HERE IS NOT THAT WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO SERVE NOT THAT WE
DON'T WANT YOU SERVING YOUR
COMMUNITY -- BUT THAT WE DO HAVE
TO RESPECT THE PROCESS OF
CITIZENSHIP -- AND THAT'S NOT
JUST ME SAYING THAT THAT'S WHAT
GOVERNOR BROWN SAID LAST YEAR
WHEN HE VETOED I THINK YOU CAN
HAVE BOTH OF THOSE POSITIONS AND
STILL VALUE THE SERVICE RIGHT --
AND SAY HEY HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT -- YO.
AND HAVE RESPECT FOR THE PROCESS
OF CITIZENSHIP -- AND I AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE I'M AT ON
THIS LEGISLATION [inaudible]
THE STRESS.
I THINK THE QUESTION FROM MY
COLLEAGUE [inaudible]
EMPHASIZES THE THE LACK OF TRUE
UNDERSTANDING THE LACK OF TRUE
KNOWLEDGE.
OF HOW BROKEN.
OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IS --
WOULD LOVE EVERYBODY TO FOLLOW
EVERY RULE.
BUT IF THERE ARE NO RULES.
AND IF PEOPLE ARE FORCED TO DO
TO PARTICIPATE IN A GOVERNMENT
TO PARTICIPATE IN VOLUNTEERING
TO PARTICIPATE.
ARE THERE STILL SEEN AS SECOND
CLASS IS STILL SEEN AS FORCED TO
SIT. TO TO HIDE IN THE SHADOWS
WE DON'T HAVE A SYSTEM.
AND BUT IT BUT THE QUESTION IT
WAS IT WAS A A A WELL MEANT
QUESTION I AM CERTAIN.
BUT IT ABSOLUTELY SHOWS THE LACK
OF KNOWLEDGE.
OF MOST PEOPLE OF HOPE BROKEN
HOPE BROKEN OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM IS AND UNTIL WE REALLY
FIND A WAY TO FIX THIS SYSTEM --
WE ARE FORCING PEOPLE INTO THE
SHADOWS WE ARE FORCING PEOPLE TO
TO BE LESS THAN WHO WHO THEY ARE --
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT
COMMENT [inaudible]
MR.
TO I WAS GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM BUT I WANTED TO RESPOND TO
THE SUGGESTION ACROSS THE AISLE
AND THE QUESTION OF WHY NOT
OBTAIN CITIZENSHIP AND SAY.
I'M NOT CONTRIBUTE THIS TO TO TO
OUR COLLEAGUE BUT I THINK THERE
ARE MANY.
WHO ARE ACROSS THE AISLE WHO
ASKED THE QUESTION ONE IT YOU
BECOME A CITIZEN?
AND IT REALLY IS A PRETEXT TO
SAY -- THE SUGGESTION THAT YOU
DON'T WANT TO BECOME A CITIZEN
OR YOU -- DON'T HAVE THE
QUALITIES TO BECOME A CITIZEN
NOT SAYING THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING BUT THAT IS OFTEN HOW
THIS QUESTION.
IS ASKED AND CURRENT POLITICAL
DISCOURSE AND I WOULD SUGGEST I
THINK IT'S AN UNDERSTATEMENT TO
SAY OUR POLITICAL OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IS IS BROKEN.
IT IS BROKEN.
BUT OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IS
ALSO A POLITICAL CONSTRUCT IT IS.
IT IS A SET OF POLICIES AND LAWS
THAT ARE PUT IN PLACE WITH THOSE
WHO CAN CONTROL POLICY.
AND IT HAS BEEN SET UP IN THE
LAST COUPLE DECADES IN A WAY TO
NOT ALLOW.
IMMIGRANTS TO HAVE A REAL PATH
TO CITIZENSHIP EVEN.
FOR MILLIONS OF INDIVIDUALS OF
HUMAN BEINGS.
WHO WANT TO BECOME CITIZENS AS A
FORMER IMMIGRANT RIGHTS ATTORNEY
IN THE LATE NINETEEN NINETIES I
CAN TELL YOU IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN?
IN THE LAST DECADE THE SYSTEM
WAS BROKEN IN THIS DECADE THE
SYSTEM IS IS BROKEN.
AND AT THIS MOMENT WITH A
PRESIDENT WHO WAS DECLARED WAR
ON OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES WHO
IS DOING EVERYTHING HE CAN
THROUGH HIS ADMINISTRATION. TO
KEEP INDIVIDUALS FROM BECOMING
CITIZENS -- THAT IS WHY.
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT.
OBTAINING CITIZENSHIP AND I JUST
WANNA SAY WITH RESPECT TO THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS I FIND IT
VERY IRONIC WE'RE HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION BECAUSE MANY OF THE
SUPREME COURT PRECEDENTS THAT
ARE CITED IN THIS COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS.
BY THE SAME SUPREME COURT
ANALYSES CASES THAT THIS
PRESIDENT.
IS TRYING TO OVERTURN. ONE TO
MARK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SUGGESTED
THAT BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
QUESTION.
PLYLER VERSUS DEL ANOTHER UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT PRECEDENT
ANOTHER CASE THAT THIS PRESIDENT.
WOULD LIKE TO OVERTURN SO --
THIS BILL THAT WE ARE
CONSIDERING I THINK IS -- IS IS
A GREAT BILL SOMETHING WE SHOULD
SUPPORT AND IF THE SENATOR WOULD
LIKE I WOULD BE HAPPY BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR -- WE HAVE TO DO
THESE THINGS AT THIS TIME WHEN
OUR SIT ARE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES ARE UNDER ASSAULT.
TO TO SAY THAT EVEN DURING THIS
DARK TIME OF HISTORY.
WHEN OUR FAMILY MEMBERS OUR WORK
FORCE OUR COMMUNITIES ARE UNDER
ASSAULT?
THERE ARE SOME OF US WHO BELIEVE
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE A PLACE IN
OUR SOCIETY WITH THAT COLLECT TO
MAKE THE MOTION OF THE SPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE WE DO
ALREADY HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
BUT THANK YOU -- MR HOLDEN.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
JUST JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES AND
I WON'T REPEAT.
THEIR ELOQUENCE IN TERMS OF
LINING AND DEFINING THE THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE ALL FACE WITH
A BROKEN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM AND
SO WE'VE BEEN HEARING THIS OF
FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME
BUT NOTHING SEEMS TO BE DONE.
HOW TO ADVANCE THE THE BALL -- I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT TO THE
WITNESSES YOUR BEING HERE
THERE'S A DEFINITION OF
CITIZENSHIP YOUR PARTICIPATED IN
THE PROCESS TO BE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY TO GET EDUCATED.
TO GIVE BACK TO US SUPPORT YOUR
CHURCHES IN YOUR COMMUNITY TO
EMPOWER THEM -- TO BE UP LIFTING
AND BE INSPIRATIONAL -- IS ALSO
THE DEFINITION OF CITIZENSHIP
AND I THINK THAT -- YOU'RE TO BE
COMMENDED -- AGAINST A LOT OF
ODDS -- BUT YOU ARE -- ALSO HERE
ILLUMINATING -- THE DARK PLACES
OF WHERE WE HAVE TO SEE THE
LIGHTS START TO SHINE BECAUSE IF
IT DOES NOT.
THEN IT CONTINUES TO BE
DIFFICULT AND I WANT.
TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
OF FOR HER CONTINUED LEADERSHIP
EVEN BEFORE SHE GOT HERE AS A
SENATOR OF THE KIND OF
COMMITMENT TO COMMUNITY AND
EMPOWERING PEOPLE TO FIGHT FOR
THEIR RIGHTS IN THE STAND UP AND
THAT'S WHAT I SEE THIS BILL
REPRESENTING AND YOU HAVE MY
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SCOUTER.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY LIKE AGAIN
NOBODY IS UNDERMINING THE
SERVICES THESE PEOPLE -- THESE.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TESTIFIED HERE
DID THIS MORNING -- ARE DOING IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
BUT WE DO HAVE TO SAY THERE IS A
BODY OF LAW ABOUT CITIZENSHIP
AND THAT AND THAT DIESEL OFFICES
BOTH ELECTED AND APPOINTED.
ARE TO BE FILLED BY PEOPLE WHO
ARE CITIZENS AND EVERYBODY OF
LAW IS POLITICAL AS A POLITICAL
CONSTRUCT.
AT THE SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE
MAKING THOSE ARGUMENTS THIS
MORNING I DOUBT THAT THEY WOULD
SAY WE DON'T HAVE TO FILE THE
FILE FALL THE ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS.
THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED IN THE
STATE WHICH ARE POLITICAL
CONSTRUCT AND THE PEOPLE JUST
IGNORED THEM THAT WOULD BE OKAY --
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY OF LAW IS A
POLITICAL CONSTRUCT THAT WE HAVE
TO GO THROUGH AND I WOULD ALSO
SAY TO THOSE.
CITIZENS WHO HAVE SWORN IN WHO
LIVE SPOKE AT THE CITIZENS WERE
IN CEREMONIES.
THEY WENT THROUGH THAT ARDUOUS
PROCESS THAT THAT TOUGH PROCESS
THAT IS.
I THINK A LOT OF US AGREE NOT
WHAT IT SHOULD BE.
BUT THEY WENT THROUGH IT AND
THEY YOU KNOW BECAME CITIZENS.
AND I THINK IT IS A LITTLE BIT
OF A SLAP IN THE FACE TO THEM TO
SAY WELL YOU WANT TO THAT
PROCESS IN.
THE BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER YOU
DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT
PROCESS IT'S UNFAIR IT WOULD BE
UNFAIR PROCESS TO DO THAT --
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY AGAIN.
FROM THE GREAT SERVICE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT CITIZENS CAN
STILL PROVIDE TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND DO COULD PROVIDE
TO THEIR COMMUNITIES -- AND I
THINK AGAIN YOU CAN LIVE IN BOTH
OF THOSE WORLDS.
AND SAY LOOK THIS THIS IS THE
LAW AND WE DO HAVE TO FOLLOW THE
LAW WHETHER WE I'M SURE ALL OF
US TO GO AROUND AND AND POINT
OUT LAWS THAT WE DON'T LIKE.
THAT WE DON'T DO WE DON'T THINK
SHOULD BE THE CASE BUT THERE LAW.
NONE THE LESS [inaudible]
A STRESS.
THERE IS NO PROCESS.
THE WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THERE
IS NO PROCESS WE HAVE DHAKA
STUDENTS.
WHO HAVE ALREADY SHOWN THE THE
THE VALUE THAT THEY ARE TO ALL
OF US?
HAVE BEEN GIVEN TEMPORARY STATUS
THERE IS NO PROCESS ZERO PROCESS
IF THERE WERE I GUARANTEE YOU I
GUARANTEE YOU THE MAJORITY THEM
WOULD HAVE ALREADY BEEN CITIZENS.
THERE IS NO PROCESS ANOTHER.
ANOTHER THING I WANTED TO
MENTION ALSO IS THAT.
THERE IS SUCH A THING AS DUAL
CITIZENSHIP WITH MANY PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE DUAL CITIZENSHIP IT
ISN'T JUST ONE CITIZENSHIP AND
NOT JUST FOR MEXICO BUT FOR MANY
OTHER COUNTRIES WHERE THEY
RETAIN THEIR CITIZENSHIP?
FROM THERE THERE.
THEIR COUNTRY OF ORIGIN OR THEIR
PARENTS COUNTRY OF ORIGIN.
AND THE U. S..
BUT AS OF NOW THERE IS NO
PROCESS FOR MANY OF THESE WHO
WOULD LOVE TO BECOME US CITIZENS
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
BECAUSE OF I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU -- I THINK I'M A CO AUTHOR
IF NOT I'D LIKE TO BE NOW.
AT FOUR THIS BILL IT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BILL -- AND I'D I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT WE CAN'T
CHANGE THE FACT THAT THERE IS NO
PROCESS AND AND I THINK THOSE OF
US WHO WHO LIVE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND FACES EVERY DAY.
WITH OUR STAFF WITH OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS WITH OUR NEIGHBORS
UNDERSTAND -- IT IN LARGELY WITH
FOLKS WHO ARE GOING THROUGH THE
IMMIGRATION PROCESS -- THAT CAN
UNDERSTAND THERE THERE'S THERE'S
NO LINE TO GET INTO -- THERE I I
DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT COMES FROM
BUT WE WE WE ARE FRUSTRATED BY
IT BUT AS FAR AS ABIDING BY THE
LAWS ARE THERE TO ABIDE BY IT I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
CHANGE.
SEEKING TO CHANGE THE LAW THAT'S
THE WHOLE POINT WHY WE CREATE
LOSSES YES THAT'S THE LOT TODAY.
AND WE WANT TO CHANGE THE LAW
WITHIN OUR POWER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE HERE AND ARE CONTRIBUTING
CAN CONTRIBUTE MORE SO THANK YOU
FOR DOING THAT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU CENTER I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
AND EIGHT I THINK WAS
UNFORTUNATE THAT PREVIOUS
GOVERNOR HAD VETOED IT WITH THE
REALLY THE MISAPPLICATION.
OF AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
CITIZENSHIP ULTIMATELY MEANS AND
THERE THERE IS TRUE VALUE TO
BEING A UNITED STATES CITIZEN
BUT CITIZENSHIP AS WE LEARN.
THROUGH ALL OF OUR EDUCATION
MEANS MORE THAN JUST WHETHER
YOUR TECHNICALLY A CITIZEN UNDER
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAW IT'S
WHAT YOU DO. FOR YOUR COMMUNITY
WITHIN YOUR COMMUNITY AND AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HAS WORKED AND A LOT OF WAYS BY
PART IN A BIPARTISAN WAY TO
RECOGNIZE.
THAT WHAT CALVET THE STANDARD
CALIFORNIA WANTS TO SET FOR
WHO'S ABLE TO WORK WITH THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES.
IS DIFFERENT THAN THE VISION
CURRENTLY BEING ESPOUSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND EVEN
POTENTIALLY OTHER STATES AND
THAT'S THE IMPORTANT DISTINCTION
HERE.
SO TO BE A UNITED STATES CITIZEN
AND HAVE VOTING RIGHTS TO BE
ABLE TO STAND FOR ELECTIVE
OFFICE AND ALL IS NOT WHAT'S
BEEN QUESTION HERE.
BUT TO BE ABLE TO FILL THE
MYRIAD OF POSITIONS.
AND GIVE BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
IN WAYS THAT MEETS OUR STANDARDS.
OUR LAWS THAT WE ARE ALLOWED TO
DO EVEN GIVEN THE FEDERAL LAWS.
IS SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
WORTHWHILE FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
DO AND EMBRACE EVERYONE IS HERE
WHO TO BE ABLE TO WORK TO THEIR
HIGHEST AND BEST.
OPPORTUNITIES THAT'S WHICH
YOU'VE BROUGHT FORWARD HOPING
WITH THIS GOVERNOR WE WE CAN GET
THIS THROUGH AND WITH THIS
GOVERNOR.
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO GET THIS SIDE
THAT WE CAN WELCOME.
THESE GREAT FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO
DO.
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES OUR
COMMUNITIES WHAT THEY ARE
EQUIPPED TO DO WILLING TO DO NOT
EVERYBODY'S WILLING TO DO THIS.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THINKING AND WITH THAT
CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE.
YOU'VE ALL BEEN SO ELOQUENCE AND
THERE'S NO NEED FOR ME TO SAY
ANYTHING MORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THAT WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHILD.
SHALL I CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE FONG.
FONG NO MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
YES I THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
SO IT'S MOVE TO SENATE BILL
.
FOUR NINETY FIVE THERE REALLY IS
A LOT.
OF PEOPLE [inaudible]
JEFF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AGAIN -- SB.
FOUR NINE FIVE UP PROHIBITS THE
COURT FROM CONSIDERING.
THE SEX GENDER IDENTITY GENDER
EXPRESSION OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OF A PARENT LEGAL GUARDIAN.
OR RELATIVE IN DETERMINING THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD FOR
THE PURPOSE OF GRANTING CUSTODY
AGAIN.
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD
IS WHAT IS -- WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE?
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW CHILD
CUSTODY DETERMINATION ARE
GOVERNED BY THE BEST INTEREST
STANDARD.
A BEST INTEREST DETERMINATION IS
A VERY HOLISTIC ANALYSIS IT
REQUIRES CONSIDERATION OF HEALTH
AND THE SAFETY AND THE WELFARE
OF THE CHILD.
THE NATURE IN THE MOUNT OF
CONTACT WITH EACH PARENT AND
OTHER.
OF LIKE RELEVANT FACTORS THE SEX
GENDER EXPRESSION GENDER
IDENTITY OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OF A PARENT.
LEGAL GUARDIAN OR RELATIVE HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL'S ABILITY TO LOVE AND
CARE FOR THEIR CHILD.
AND THEREFORE WE BELIEVE SHOULD
NOT BE CONSIDERED IN DETERMINING
CUSTODY.
OF I HAVE WITH US TODAY
WITNESSES REBEKAH BIRMINGHAM OF
LOG LONG BEACH BAR ASSOCIATION
MANDY TAYLOR OF THE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
POLICY INSTITUTE.
AND JENNIFER RICHARD MY CHIEF OF
STAFF.
THE BILL THANK YOU BUT WE DO
HAVE A MOTION IS THERE A SECOND.
AND A SECOND FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MANDY TAYLOR
AND I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON AS BEFORE NINETY FIVE
BIAS FREE CHILD CUSTODY.
I'M A PART OF THE WOMEN'S POLICY
INSTITUTE LGBT Q. I A JUSTICE
TEAM ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF THE
SPELL COULD YOU BE MORE CLOSELY
IN LIKE BUDGET MAKE SURE YOU'RE
GETTING.
OR DID.
BETTER I THINK SO THANK YOU.
I AM A SOCIAL WORKER AND
ADVOCATE A MEMBER OF THE QUEER
AND TRANS COMMUNITY AND THE
PARENT OF AN AMAZING KID.
WHEN MY DAUGHTER WAS AN INFANT I
LEFT MY ABUSIVE BOYFRIEND AND
FILED FOR FULL CUSTODY TO ENSURE
HER SAFETY? FOR THE LAST
THIRTEEN YEARS I HAVE HAD FULL
PHYSICAL CUSTODY AND THE FAMILY
COURT HAS CONSISTENTLY ENFORCED
SUPERVISED PARENTING TIME FOR MY
CO PARENT.
OUR CHILD SAFETY AND WELL BEING
WAS PARAMOUNT TO ME.
BECAUSE OF THAT FOR YEARS DURING
THE LENGTHY CUSTODY PROCESS I
DID NOT FEEL SAFE COMING OUT
ABOUT MY SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
MY EX HAD MADE HIS BELIEFS ABOUT
THE LGBTQ.
COMMUNITY VERY CLEAR AND I KNEW
THAT I CAN EXPECT RETALIATION IF
YOU KNEW MY SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
I WAS A SINGLE PARENT WITH AN
INFANT AT NO COLLEGE DEGREE I
WAS IN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROGRAM TRYING TO HEAL AND DEAL
WITH MY TRAUMA.
I WAS ON WELFARE AND ATTENDING
SCHOOL FULL TIME I DIDN'T HAVE
THE MONEY TO HIRE AN ATTORNEY OR
THE TIME AND KNOWLEDGE TO
RESEARCH CASE LAW.
IF I COULDN'T GUARANTEE AN
UNBIASED JUDGE MEDIATOR OR
OPPOSING COUNSEL BEING OUT WITH
TOO MUCH OF A RISK TO MY
DAUGHTER'S SAFETY.
I WAITED THREE YEARS TO BE
PUBLICLY OUT.
I WAITED UNTIL I FINISHED SCHOOL
I WAITED UNTIL I WAS SOLIDLY
MIDDLE CLASS.
I WAITED UNTIL I CAN AFFORD AN
ATTORNEY I WAITED UNTIL I HAD A
COMMUNITY THAT HELPED ME FEEL
SAFE.
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO WAIT LIKE
I DID.
BY CODIFYING AND CLARIFYING CASE
LAW INTO STATUTE YOU HELP
PROTECT CHILDREN BY ENSURING
THAT BIAS AND DISCRIMINATION I
HAVE NO PLACE WHEN DETERMINING
THE BEST INTERESTS OF A CHILD.
BY PUTTING THESE PROTECTIONS
INTO THE FAMILY COAT YOU REDUCE
BARRIERS FOR LOW INCOME PARENTS
WHO ARE ON REPRESENTED BY
COUNSEL.
AND SUPPORT COMMUNITY NETWORKS
BY PROVIDING CLEARLY ARTICULATED
AND ACCESSIBLE PROTECTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION TO ENSURE BIAS
FREE TRIAL CUSTODY ALL CHILDREN
DESERVE TO BE SAFE CARED FOR AND
LOVED IN THEIR OWN HOME.
THERE'S NO ROOM FOR BIAS OR
DISCRIMINATION.
THANK YOU X. WITH US PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU SENATOR
DORADO MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RITA
BIRMINGHAM I'M PRESIDENT ELECT
OF THE LONG BEACH BAR
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
WE REPRESENT MANY FAMILIES IN
LAW UP ABOUT CUSTODY
GUARDIANSHIP ADOPTION
PROCEEDINGS.
AS SENATOR DORADO SAID THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD IS THE
LEGAL STANDARD IN MAKING THESE
BECAUSE TONY OLD DETERMINATIONS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU TO
AMEND FAMILY CODE SECTION THIRTY
ELEVEN THIRTY TWENTY AND THIRTY
FORTY TO MAKE CLEAR THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD FACTORS
REMADE WELL BECOME BIAS FREE.
A BEST INTEREST ANALYSIS COVERS
MANY FACTORS THEY INCLUDE THE
MOST IMPORTANT.
WHICH ARE THE HEALTH THE SAFETY
AND THE WELFARE OF THE CHILD.
THE EMOTIONAL TIES BETWEEN A
PARENT AND A CHILD.
APPEARANCE ABILITY TO CARE FOR
THEIR CHILD EMOTIONALLY AND
PHYSICALLY.
THE CHILD'S TIES TO THEIR HOME
AND THEIR COMMUNITY.
THERE OTHER RELEVANT FACTORS
UNDER SP FOUR NINETY FIVE NONE
OF THESE WILL CHANGE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THERE ARE
OLD CONTROLLING CASES OUT THERE.
WHICH ALSO PERMIT THE COURT TO
CONSIDER A RELEVANT FACTORS SUCH
AS THE LGBT Q. STATUS OF A
PARENT.
THE LEAD CASE REGARDING NON
HETEROSEXUAL PARENTS FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS
MARRIAGE A BIRD SAUL WHICH
ALLOWS THE COURT EVEN TODAY. TO
CONSIDER THE SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OF A PARENT AND REALLY WHETHER
IT HARMS THE CHILD.
A PARENT SEX OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION IS IRRELEVANT TO THE
BEST INTEREST ANALYSIS.
STUDY AFTER STUDY SHOWS THIS
IT'S TIME TO CLARIFY THE CASE
LAW AND BRING THE LAWN TO
CONFORMITY WITH THE SCIENCE
WHICH OVERWHELMINGLY SHOWS
HAVING IT LGBT Q. PARENT DOES
NOT HARM A CHILD.
THIS FACTOR SHOULD BE REMOVED
FROM CUSTODY DETERMINATION SO
THAT EVERY PARENT IS VIEWED
EQUALLY.
I ALSO KNOW THAT AS DRAFTED THIS
LEGISLATION WILL MAKE THE LAW
BIAS FREE WITH RESPECT TO EVERY
PARENT.
NOT JUST LGBT Q. PARENTS THE
FOCUS WILL REMAIN ON THE CHILD.
ELIMINATING THIS A RELEVANT
FACTOR THESE RELEVANT FACTORS
FROM A BEST INTEREST ANALYSIS
WILL BENEFIT LITIGANTS MANY OF
WHOM ARE PROBE HER.
WITH CLEAR IN PLAIN LANGUAGE ON
THE FACE OF THE STATUTE IT WILL
MOSTLY BENEFIT CHILDREN BY
REDUCING THE ACRIMONY IN CHILD
CUSTODY DETERMINATIONS.
WE ASKED TODAY FOR YOUR VOTE TO
MOVE SB.
FOUR NINETY FIVE THANK YOU
THAT'S WITH US PLEASE.
AND UP OKAY BUT IN WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB FOUR NINETY FIVE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RACHEL WALLACE ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MEDI HIRED CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SAY NOT BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I AND I
THINK I KNOW I HAVE TALKED TO
THE AUTHOR AND I THINK I
UNDERSTAND -- THE I THIS SHOULD
BE THE ANSWER THE QUESTION BY
ONE MAKE SURE.
WE ARE ONLY TALKING ABOUT SEXUAL
ORIENTATION EIGHT JUDGE COULD
STILL PREFER OR DECIDE THAT A A
TWO PARENT HOUSEHOLD IS
PREFERABLE OVER ONE PARENT
HOUSEHOLD.
THAT DOESN'T GO TO GENDER.
OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
CRACKED ME THERE'S AN EVEN IF
THAT HAPPENS.
TO TO ALIGN WITH SEXUAL
ORIENTATION [inaudible]
IS.
YOUR WELL I MEAN OBVIOUSLY I
WOULD THINK IF IT'S AT AS A GAY
COUPLE A MERRY GAY COUPLE.
IN FAMILY LAW OFTEN ONE OF THE
FACTORS IS IF YOU HAVE A TWO
PARENT HOUSEHOLD IT'S A
PREFERENCE -- I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THAT THERE'S
NOTHING THAT WOULD -- PREVENT
EVEN IF THAT TWO PARENT
HOUSEHOLD IS EIGHTY MALE FEMALE.
PARENT COMPARED TO EIGHT LGBT
KILL OTHER PARENT BUT I THINK
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE YES I THINK
THE WITH THAT THAT THE BILL IS
WRITTEN.
IS THE FOCUS IS A WHAT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD WHICH
IS WHAT THE INPUT THE IMPORTANT
PIECE IS AND SO THE PREFERENCE
FOR A STABLE HOUSEHOLD.
YES AS YOU MIGHT HAVE A SINGLE
PARENT ANY MORE STABLE HOUSEHOLD
RATHER THAN A TWO PARENT FAMILY
BUT IF A TWO PARENT FAMILY IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST YES AND WITH
THIS BILL WOULD SAY IS.
IS IF THAT'S A SAME SEX COUPLE
OR OR NOT.
THAT'S NOT RELEVANT RELEVANT TO
THE QUESTION W. I JUST WANNA
MAKE YEAH.
I DON'T THINK I NEED TO RE SPANK
YOU DID SUCH A GREAT.
OTHER QUESTIONS MISS GALLAGHER
AND I THINK MAYBE GETTING OUT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS -- WHY NOT
HAVE THE FREE I THINK THERE'S
SOME PRISONERS SO LONG AS IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT'S EVIDENCE OF
A DETRIMENT TO THE CHILD?
YOU KNOW [inaudible]
THE YOU KNOW WHAT SOMEONE IS
SHOULD NOT MATTER -- ALWAYS THE
COURT IS LOOKING AT WHAT IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD
PERIOD.
RIGHT -- BUT WHAT I'M WORRIED
ABOUT WITHOUT SOME KIND OF I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS LANGUAGE
AND MAYBE YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT --
THAT YOU KNOW THESE FAMILY LAW
CASES BECOME VERY CONTENTIOUS
RIGHT AND IF THERE'S A DECISION
MADE ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
SOME OF THE SAY WELL YOU DID IT
BECAUSE OF THIS YOU KNOW.
AND ALMOST LIKE LEADS TO LIKE
MORE LITIGATION A MORE FIGHTS --
ACTUALLY RIGHT THAT IS KIND OF
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT MAY
RESPOND YES.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR QUESTION -- THE WAY THAT
THESE CUSTODY DETERMINATIONS
WORK.
WHEN A JUDICIAL OFFICER AND BY
THE WAY THE JUDGES AND ALL OF
THE FAMILY LAW SPECIALIST?
OR FOR THE S. AND THAT IS IT ONE
TOUGH GROUP TO GET TO AGREE OKAY
THIS IS THE SANCTUM SANCTORUM OF
THE BEST INTEREST. FOR THE CHILD.
BUT I THINK THE QUESTION YOU'RE
GETTING AT AND IT IS A REALLY
SUBTLE DISTINCTION.
WHAT IF SOMEBODY WALKS IN AND
THERE'S SOMETHING REALLY
APPROPRIATE GOAL INAPPROPRIATE
GOING ON SEXUAL IT?
UNDER THIS LAW IT DOES NOT
MATTER WHO'S DOING IT I DON'T
CARE IF THEY'RE GAY STRAIGHT BI.
OUT ANY TYPE OF LGBT Q..
IF THERE'S SOMETHING APPROPRIATE
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE.
WHAT WE'RE GETTING AT HERE IS
NOT LABELING IT INAPPROPRIATE ME
MERELY BECAUSE PERHAPS SOMEONE?
DOESN'T LIKE GAYS RIGHT.
THE TREATS EVERYBODY THE SAME.
IN OTHER IF I CAN I THINK THAT
ANSWERS THE QUESTION OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND THAT I I
FEEL THIS IS [inaudible]
APPROPRIATE.
COULD HAVE SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE
A WHILE AGO SOMETIMES WE DO
THINGS THAT.
THEY REALLY WEAK WE HAVE TO DO
THIS.
BUT IT SHOULD BE CLEAR THE FOCUS
ON WHAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THAT CHILD.
AND CERTAIN ATTRIBUTES OF THE
PARENT.
NOT RELEVANT WE WOULD NEVER SAY
SOMEONE HAS BLACK HAIR BROWN
HAIR.
BLOOD HAIR IN IN IN LOOK AT SOME
OTHER PHYSICAL ATTRIBUTES SO.
WE NEED TO GET A LITTLE BIT
SMARTER ABOUT THIS AND LOOK AT
WHAT'S AT THE PASSAGE THE CHILD.
CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THAT'S IT FIVE OF RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR WE DO
HAVE A MOTION TO SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY.
STONE AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CHAU.
CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
CONSULTS AYE HOLDEN.
AND I KALRA.
KALRA AYE FONG [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
IN CHINA I PETRIE-NORRIS RADIUS
[inaudible]
A SIGH.
WITH.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU.
RIGHT LOOKS LIKE THAT TAKES US
TO ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FIVE FORTY
FOUR SENATOR UMBERG.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- AHEAD BEFORE YOU SB
FIVE FOUR FOUR FIRST LET ME
BEGIN BY BY THANKING YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR IMPROVING THE
BILL THIS SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
ARE MOST WELCOME AND I CERTAINLY
ACCEPT THEM.
THANK YOU.
THE PURPOSE OF SB FIVE FOUR FOUR
IS TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE -- WITH
RESPECT TO APPLICANTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BAR.
IF AN APPLICANT HAS A BLEMISH ON
HIS OR HER RECORD SO FOR EXAMPLE --
IF YOU HAVE A SHOPLIFTING
CONVICTION WHEN YOU'RE NINETEEN
YEARS OLD -- AT THAT POINT TIME
THE BAR ISSUE SIGNED A WAIVER
WHICH RELEASES ALL YOUR RECORDS
YOUR HEALTH RECORDS EMPLOYMENT
RECORDS INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH
RECORDS SO FOR EXAMPLE IF.
YOU HAVE BEEN OR WHILE IN LAW
SCHOOL YOUR SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
BOB IF YOU CONSULT THE
PSYCHIATRISTS OR COUNSELOR THOSE
RECORDS ARE THEN SUBJECT TO
REVIEW BY THE STATE BAR THE SAME
IS TRUE IF YOU HAPPEN TO HAVE.
PTSD FROM YOUR TIME IN MILITARY
SERVICE OR FROM OTHER ANY OTHER
REASON.
WHAT WHAT?
THE IMPACT OF THAT IS THE SECOND
AND THIRD IMPACT IS THAT YOU MAY
WILL NOT SEEK COUNSELING FOR
FEAR OF HAVING.
THOSE RECORDS EXPOSED OF THE
EMBARRASSMENT THAT MAN SO SO THE
PURPOSE OF SB FIVE FOUR FOUR IT
IS SIMPLY.
TO PREVENT.
THE STATE BAR EXAMINERS AND
STAFF FROM ACCESSING MENTAL
HEALTH RECORDS UNLESS YOU
PROVIDE THEM VOLUNTARILY IT'S A
SIMPLE BILL.
AND I URGE AYE BOAT THANK YOU
WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THE BILL.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
YOUR CHILD DISABILITY RIGHT
THERE WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND WE PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS OF THE
AUTHOR -- MAKING IT CLEAR THAT --
MENTAL HEALTH RECORDS ARE
CLEARLY OUT OF POUNDS FOR THE
PART TO BE USING WHEN MAKING
DETERMINATIONS OF MORAL
CHARACTER FOR ADMISSION TO THE
BAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND MANY HIGHER CALIFORNIA'S
ALERT IS ADVOCACY -- WE'RE ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
START SEEING NONE OF BRING IT
BACK QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT SEEING NONE CENTER YOU MAY
CLOSE UP THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUGGESTION IMPROVEMENTS I URGE
Là VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHAO [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA IPHONE.
FONG FIVE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
REYES.
REYES AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SENATOR STERN. SIX AS TO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE SB.
SIX THIRTY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
MEMBERS SB SIX THIRTY WOULD GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE MUCH
NEEDED TOOL IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
MANY OF US DON'T REALIZE THIS
SCORED EXISTS IN OUR OWN
BACKYARDS.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES DRIVING DOWN
A NORMAL CITY STREET.
YOU MAY PASSED BY A PLACE THAT
LOOKS LIKE.
A MASSAGE PARLOR OR SOME OTHER
PLACE OF SOME SERVICE THAT IS
LEGITIMATE IN FACT.
THERE'S THE EXPLOITATION HUMAN
BEINGS GOING ON JUST LAST WEEK
IN SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
WE HAD A PLACE BUSTED -- THAT
WAS EXPLOITING HUNDREDS OF WOMEN --
AND WE'VE DONE SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS AS A STATE TO SAY THAT
EVERY ONE OF THESE
ESTABLISHMENTS HAS TO POST AT
LEAST AT A MINIMUM HAS TO POST
REQUIREMENTS.
ABOUT -- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LIFELINE TO CALL THIS HOTLINE --
NOW YOU CAN ACTUALLY TEXT BE
FREE TO THE HOT LINE IF YOU ARE
IN THE POSITION OF SAFETY TO
ACTUALLY CALL THE HOTLINE WE
FOUND THIS TO BE VERY EFFECTIVE
THE PROBLEM IS.
FOLKS ARE POSTING THE POSTERS.
THERE'S NO TOOLS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO ENFORCE OUR STATE
LAW.
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE OPTION NOT A
MANDATE BUT AN OPTION TO ENFORCE --
THIS POSTER REQUIREMENT -- AND
LOCAL ESTABLISHMENTS AND THAT'S
BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ESTABLISHMENTS THAT'S AIRPORTS
AND BUS STATIONS BUT WE'VE HAD
BETTER BETTER COMPLIANCE THERE
BUT MUCH WORSE IN MASSAGE
PARLORS STRIP CLUBS IN OTHER
PLACE THAT.
YOU CAN IMAGINE -- I DON'T THINK
THIS BILL IS VERY MUCH
OPPOSITION BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE AND I HAVE YOUR MELANIE
CUEVAS WITH ME WHO'S WITH THE
COALITION AGAINST SLAVERY AND
TRAFFICKING.
THANK.
THERE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING TURN NUMBERS
MELANIE CUEVAS -- WITH CAN
TUNNEL IT'S AN APARTMENT ON
BEHALF OF CAST THE COALITION TO
ABOLISH SLAVERY AND TRAFFICKING.
BASED IN LOS ANGELES IT'S THE
LARGEST MOST COMPREHENSIVE
SERVICE PROVIDER TO VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN THE UNITED
STATES -- I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY THANKING THE SENATOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AS WELL AS ANTI
HUMAN TRAFFICKING -- EFFORTS IN
THE LEGISLATURE -- ALONG WITH
THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH
WOMEN I'M CAST WAS A SPONSOR OF
THE SB ELEVEN NINETY THREE AND
TWO THOUSAND TWO WITH AND PART
TIME SENATOR STEINBERG --
THOUGHT LEGISLATION WAS CRAFTED
BASED ON INPUT OF SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THAT VICTIMS
ONE DON'T HAVE INFORMATION TO
REACH OUT FOR HELP AND TO HAVE A
LOT OF HESITATION IN CONTACTING
GOVERNMENT OR LAW ENFORCEMENT
HOTLINE.
SURVIVORS WE WORKED WITH
INDICATED THAT THEY BELIEVE THE
HOTLY POSTERS AND PUBLIC PLACES
WOULD HELP VICTIMS ACCESS THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEEDED TO
SEEK THE HELP.
AND THE US ELEVEN NINETY THREE
WAS BORN REQUIRING SPECIFIC
BUSINESSES TO POST NOTICES IN
PUBLIC PLACES WITH INFORMATION
TO NGO OPERATE AT HOTLINES.
SINCE THAT LEGISLATION WENT INTO
A FACT IN TWENTY THIRTEEN WE
HAVE WORKED WITH LOCAL CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION AND AS THE
SENATOR NOTED UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVE NOT FOUND THAT --
VOLUNTEERS OF AND CJ W. BOTH IN
LOS ANGELES AND SACRAMENTO
REVEALED THAT LESS THAN 30% OF
BUSINESSES IN BOTH REGIONS
ACTUALLY HAD THE POSTERS UP.
DESPITE REPEATED DOES HAVE
VISITS BY THE VOLUNTEERS.
SO IN LIGHT OF THAT LACK OF
COMPLIANCE THE NEXT STEP WOULD
BE FOR CITY OR COUNTY TO SEEK
ENFORCEMENT OF THESE PROVISIONS.
DUE TO THE LACK OF CLARITY AND
ELEVEN NINETY THREE WERE
PRESENTING A SIMPLE SOLUTION AND
SB SIX THIRTY WHICH ALLOWS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO TAILOR
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS TO USE
THEIR RESOURCES MOST EFFECTIVELY.
LASTLY GIVEN THE NEED FOR
VICTIMS TO HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION AND THE DESIRE FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO ENSURE
THAT VICTIMS HAVE ACCESS AS
REQUIRED BY CURRENT LAW.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS LEGISLATION ON
BEHALF OF THE MANY VICTIMS THAT
WE SERVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY
MIKE FEWER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS CHAIR RYAN SHERMAN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS OF CITY ATTORNEY
FEWER IN IN THIS FIGHT -- BUT
THE ENFORCEMENT SIDE IS NOT
ENOUGH IF WE DON'T HAVE ACT.
ADEQUATE DETERRENCE AND
LIFELINES HOPEFULLY THIS WILL
START TO IMPROVE THAT PIECE THE
EQUATION AND FINALLY AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND MOTION IS TO
PASS KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHAU.
CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE FONG FONG I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
PETRIE-NORRIS RAYOS.
RESIDE.
THAT BILLS OUT.
WHILE WE WAIT FOR SENATOR MINING
HOPEFULLY HE'S GOING TO BE HERE
SOON I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA UNLESS SOMEONE
LIKE TO REMOVE ITEM.
THERE IS A OCEAN AND A SECOND ON
CONSENT CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE CHAU [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
COLOR IPHONE.
FONG I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I PETRIE-NORRIS
REYES.
REYES I THOSE ITEMS ARE OUT THAT
IS H. R. THIRTY FOUR MCCARTY SB
SIXTY ATKINS AND SB THREE ONE
FOUR TWO DODD.
I AM TOLD CENTER MONEY IS ON
HERE IS CENTER MINING WELCOME.
WE'LL DO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
[inaudible]
SIX FORTY FIVE HI.
GOOD MORNING MORNINGSTAR CHAIR
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE YOUR
WAITING WE'LL STILL LITTLE OUT
OF BREATH HERE MAKE IN THE RAIN.
IF I COULD ASK THE SERGEANT TO
HELP.
DISTRIBUTE THESE PHOTOS FOR
SUPPORT ONE OF MY WITNESSES.
SO MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY FIVE
PROTECTS DYING VICTIMS WHO
SUFFER FROM TO SPECIFIC DISEASES.
MESOTHELIOMA AND SILICOSIS.
FROM DAYS AND DAYS OF ABUSE OF
DEPOSITIONS QUESTIONING IN CIVIL
CASES.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES A RECURRING
PROBLEM.
THE PROBLEM EXISTS BECAUSE OF AN
UNINTENDED LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT
LAW.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE ENACTED
IN TWENTY TWELVE LIMITED MOST
DEPOSITIONS TO SEVEN HOURS.
THE SAME IS IN FEDERAL MATTERS.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE AND
NATIONALLY COVERED ALL CIVIL
CASES.
BUT AFTER DISCUSSIONS AND
HEARINGS THE LEGISLATURE AMENDED
THE BILL TO INCLUDE VERY SIX
SECTIONS TO THE SEVEN HOUR LIMIT.
EXCEPTIONS FOR EXPERT AND OTHER
SPECIALIZED WITNESSES FOR ALL
EMPLOYMENT CASES AND FOR COMPLEX
CASES.
HOWEVER IT WAS NEVER THE INTENT.
TO EXEMPT DYING PATIENTS FROM
THE SEVEN HOUR LIMIT.
AND SUBJECT THEM TWO DAYS AND
DAYS OF CROSS EXAMINATION.
BUT THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IT'S NOT HUMANE.
DESPITE CURRENT LAW.
DEPOSITIONS OF END STAGE
MESOTHELIOMA PATIENTS ALMOST
ALWAYS INVOLVE TWENTY HOURS OR
MORE.
OF QUESTIONING BY DEFENDANTS.
THIS IS BECAUSE CURRENT LAW
INCLUDES A LOOPHOLE.
A LOOPHOLE WHICH ALLOWS ONE SIZE
FITS ALL CASE MANAGEMENT ORDERS
TO OVERRIDE EVERYTHING IN THE
LAW.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THE
PLAINTIFF IS CLOSE TO DYING.
I UNDERSTAND THAT SEVEN HOURS OF
ON THE RECORD INTERROGATION OF A
DYING.
MESOTHELIOMA PATIENT OR
SILICOSIS PATIENT IS STRESSFUL
BECAUSE IT GENERALLY TAKES A
FULL TWO OR THREE DAYS OF TIME.
SEVEN HOURS OF DEPOSITION.
TAKES TWO OR THREE DAYS TO
COMPLETE.
YOU HEAR SEVEN HOURS YOU THINK
OF THAT SAID DAY OF DEPOSITION.
NO WE'RE TALKING TWO OR THREE
DAYS TO COMPLETE SEVEN HOURS OF
DEPOSITION.
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY FIVE
LIMITS DEPOSITIONS OF DYING
MESOTHELIOMA AND SILICOSIS
PATIENTS TO SEVEN HOURS.
IN ADDITION THE COURT IN ITS
DISCRETION MAY GRANT UP TO THREE
MORE DEPOSITION HOURS UPON
REQUEST BY DEFENSE COUNSEL IN
THE INTEREST OF FAIRNESS.
AS LONG AS THE HEALTH OF THE
DEPONENT DOES NOT APPEAR
ENDANGERED BY THE GRANT OF
ADDITIONAL TIME.
YOUR HILL FOR MY ROUTE YOU'LL
HEAR FROM MY WITNESSES THIS
MORNING MICHELLE PROXMIRE.
WHO IS THAT OUR FATHERS
DEPOSITION IN A TYPICAL CASE?
HE WAS DEPOSED FOR TWELVE DAYS.
HIS ATTORNEYS TRIED TO USE
EXISTING LAW TO LIMIT THE
INTERROGATION.
BUT THE COURT APPLIED ITS CASE
MANAGEMENT ORDER IN WOULD NOT
ALLOW ANY LIMITATIONS.
IS MICHELLE REPORT.
THE TWELVE DAY DEPOSITION.
WAS EXTREMELY DEBILITATING AND
WAS CONCLUDED ON HIS DEATH BED
IN THEIR OWN HOME.
WHERE THE DEFENSE COUNSEL CAME?
YOU WILL ALSO HEAR FROM JEREMY
SMITH AT THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHO REPRESENTS THE VAST MAJORITY
OF WORKERS EXPOSED TO ASBESTOS
AND SILICA?
MEMBER SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
FIVE IT'S A NARROW BILL.
IT WILL GREATLY HELP VICTIMS OF
THE DAY OF THESE TO SPECIFIC
DISEASES ONLY.
BECAUSE THESE DISEASES ARE
EXTRAORDINARILY PAINFUL AT THE
END OF LIFE.
IT WILL SURE THESE VICTIMS ARE
TREATED HUMANELY IN THE CIVIL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
DURING THE LAST WEEKS OF THEIR
LIVES.
AND JUST BEFORE I CLOSE.
SOME OF RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT
COMPROMISED OFFERS.
BY THE OPPONENTS YOU'LL HEAR
FROM THEM.
LAST YEAR -- THEY OPPOSED A BILL
THAT HAD AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN
HOURS THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
MULTIPLE DAYS.
AND NOW THEY PROPOSE THAT AS A
POSSIBLE COMPROMISE WHAT YOU
NEED TO KNOW MEMBERS.
IN THESE CASES.
IF THE PLAINTIFF DIES BEFORE THE
CASE IS CONCLUDED.
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR PAIN AND SUFFERING DAMAGES.
ONLY MEDICAL DAMAGES.
SO YOU'VE GOT A SYSTEM WITH A
BUILT IN.
INCENTIVE TO DRAG OUT THE
DISCOVERY PROCESS TO DRAG OUT
THE DEPOSITION PROCESS.
BECAUSE IT LIMITS WHAT THE
DEFENDANTS HAVE TO PAY OUT IF
THEY CAN RUN OUT THE CLOCK.
IN THE PLAINTIFF DIES THANK YOU.
BEFORE THE COMPLETION.
IT'S A BILL TEN FLAW IN THE
SYSTEM WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT
A LIMITED UNIVERSE.
THESE ARE A SMALL NUMBER OF
CASES EACH YEAR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW MORE THAN A HUNDRED CASES
PER YEAR.
AGAIN THE DEFINITION IN THIS
BILL.
A DOCTOR HAS TO CONCLUDE AND
PROVIDE WRITTEN INSTRUCTION TO
THE COURT.
THAT THE PATIENT THE PLAINTIFF
HAS LESS.
THEN SIX MONTHS TO LIVE.
AND FINALLY I HAVE IN FRONT OF
ME SOME OF THE INTERROGATORIES
FROM A CASE.
PLAINTIFFS HAVE TO RESPOND TO
WRITTEN INTERROGATORIES BEFORE
THE DEPOSITIONS.
ALL THE INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE
THEY WORK WHAT THEY WORKED WITH.
TENURE OF WORK POSITIONS HELD.
NUMBERS OF DIFFERENT EMPLOYERS.
THAT THE OPPONENTS WHO ARGUE
WELL THESE ARE MULTI DEFENDING
CASES AND YOU'RE GONNA LIMIT.
THE DUE PROCESS THEIR ABILITY TO
CROSS EXAMINE WITNESSES.
THEY CAN ASK ANY QUESTION THEY
WANT.
IN INTERROGATORIES THEY OFTEN
JUST REPEAT.
THE INTERROGATORY QUESTIONS WITH
THE PATIENT OFTEN IN THEIR DEATH
BED TO DRAG OUT THE CLOCK.
WITH THE PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR.
AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO PRESENT.
OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
STARTING WITH MICHELLE BROCK
MEYER.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS MICHELLE BROOKMEYER.
RICHARD LLOYD SMITH WAS MY
FATHER.
HE WORKED AS A DRY WHILE OTHER
HIS ENTIRE ADULT LIFE.
WE HAVE A PICTURE OF HIM AT HOME
WHEN I WAS YOUNG.
HIS HEIR CRUSTY WITH WHITE
DRYWALL JOINT COMPOUND KICKED IN
IT.
SOME OF THEM WITH MY BROTHER AND
I ON HIS LAP.
LITTLE DID HE KNOW THAT THE
MATERIAL HE USE STATED A FOR SO
MANY YEARS.
WOULD CAUSE HIS DEATH YEARS
LATER.
AFTER HIS DOCTORS TOLD HIM THAT
HE HAD MESOTHELIOMA.
AND ONLY HAD A FEW MONTHS TO
LIVE.
MY FATHER CHOSE TO FILE A
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE COMPANIES
THAT MADE MONEY.
SELLING THE PRODUCTS.
THE CAUSES CANCER.
HE WAS A PROUD MAN AND INSISTED.
THAT WE FIND A RESPECTABLE
ATTORNEY.
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO TELL HIS
STORY.
HE THOUGHT.
IT MIGHT HELP OTHERS IF WE CAN
HOLD THE COMPANIES THAT CHOSE TO
PROFIT.
FROM SELL SELLING AS FAST AS
CONTAINING TRAVEL PRODUCTS EVEN
THOUGH THEY KNEW IT WOULD KILL
AND INJURE THOSE WHO USE THE
PRODUCT.
WE WERE TOLD THAT HIS CASE WOULD
BE AS SIMPLE AS AN IS BEST OKAY
AS COULD BE.
THERE WERE TWENTY DEFENDANTS AND
HIS ONLY EXPOSURE TO ASBESTOS
WAS FOR WORKING FROM WORKING AS
A DRY WALLER.
THE DEPOSITION STARTED IN A
LOCAL HOTEL ROOM.
IT HAD TO BE MOVED TO MY HOUSE.
BECAUSE MY DYING FATHER COULD
BETTER BE CARED FOR AT HOME.
I WAS PRESENT FOR ALL OF THE
DEPOSITION BECAUSE I WAS MY
FATHER'S CHARACTER.
MY DAD COULD ANSWER QUESTIONS
FOR ABOUT FORTY FIVE MINUTES AT
A TIME.
AND THEN HE WOULD NEED A BREAK.
TO TAKE MEDICINE.
OSPREY THE MUCUS THAT CONSTANTLY
GATHERED IN HIS MOUTH FROM HIS
LUNGS.
USE THE RESTROOM.
AND TRY TO GATHER STRENGTH AND
FOCUS TO INDOOR THE NEXT FORTY
FIVE MINUTES OF QUESTIONING.
THE LAWYERS FOR THE AS FAST AS
DEFENDANTS INTERROGATED MY
FATHER FOR TWELVE DAYS ACROSS
SIX WEEKS.
AS HE WENT IN AND OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL.
INSTEAD OF ASKING HIM
STRAIGHTFORWARD QUESTIONS LIKE
DID YOU WORK WITH OUR PRODUCTS.
THEY ASKED HIM UNLESS QUESTIONS.
LIKE WHETHER HE COULD REMEMBER
EVERY BUILDING OR A DRESS THAT
HE EVER STEPPED IN AND OUT OF IT
WAS CLEAR TO ME THAT THEIR GOAL
WAS TO SEE IF HE COULD SURVIVE
THE DEPOSITION.
HIS ATTORNEY ADVISED US THAT IF
HE DID NOT COMPLETE THE
DEPOSITION NO MATTER HOW LONG IT
LASTED.
THE JUDGE WOULD LIKELY EXCLUDE
ALL OF HIS TESTIMONY FROM BEING
USED AT TRIAL -- ATTORNEY EVEN
US THE JUDGE TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT
OF TIME THE AS FAST AS
DEFENDANTS.
INTERROGATED MY FATHER. TO
FOURTEEN HOURS.
THE DEFENDANTS WOULDN'T STOP AND
THE JUDGE DIDN'T LIMIT THE TIME.
MY DAD'S ENTIRE GOAL IN LIFE.
TURN TO FOCUSING TO SEE IF YOU
CAN MAKE IT THROUGH THE ANALYST
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
HE DID [inaudible]
I LESS THAN A WEEK LATER.
YOU HAVE PICTURES OF MY DOG.
AS HE BEGAN THE DEPOSITION.
AND A PICTURE OF THE LAST DAY OF
THE DEPOSITION.
THE DEFENDANT LAWYERS TOOK.
THE DEFENDANTS LAWYERS TOOK
EVERY STRATEGIC.
ADVANTAGE THE CODE.
BUT IT WAS INHUMANE TO ALLOW
THEM TO INTERROGATE.
MY JOB THIS WHITE.
I DON'T BLAME THE LAWYERS FOR
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE CURRENT
RULES.
BUT I HOPE THAT HIS SUFFERING.
AND MY RETELLING OF IT.
CAN HELP CHANGE THE RULES AND
PROTECT OTHERS IN THE FUTURE.
THAT'S WHERE MY WHAT MY DAD.
HOPE TO DO.
MIGHT EVEN BRING IN A CASE HE
WANTED TO BRING OUT HOW UNFAIR
IT WAS.
THAT HE WAS WORKING WITH A
DANGEROUS.
DEATH INDUCING PRISON WITHOUT
ANY WARNING.
HE HOPED HE COULD PROTECT OTHER
WORKERS IN THE FUTURE.
AND I HOPE TO HELP THEM AS WELL.
IF THEY ARE DYING AND FACED IN
HUMANE DEPOSITIONS.
I ASK FOR YOUR HELP IN TURN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANKS WITH US PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL --
WE REPRESENT FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE AT ADVOCATE ON BEHALF
OF THE SICK AND DYING.
A WORKERS WHO IN THE COURT
SYSTEM NOW AND THE UNDEAD REALLY
THOUSANDS OF OTHERS WHO HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED. TO ASBESTOS OR
SILICON THEIR CAREERS.
WHAT'S NOT A LARGE NUMBER OF
FOLKS WHO ARE STRUCK WITH THESE
TWO DISEASES.
THESE THESE ARE EXTRAORDINARILY
PAINFUL WAYS TO DIE.
THERE IS NO CURE FOR EITHER AND
THE VICTIM DROWNED SO DEATH.
WITH MESOTHELIOMA.
AND SUFFOLK OR SUFFER GETS THE
DEATH WITH SILICOSIS.
AND THESE VICTIMS SHOULDN'T BE
VICTIMIZED TWICE AND THEY DIDN'T
KNOW THEY WERE BEING EXPOSED TO
TOXIC THAT WERE KILLED IN
PAINFULLY IN TWENTY OR THIRTY
YEARS.
OR KILL THEIR SPOUSES OR
CHILDREN.
BECAUSE THEY BROUGHT THE
HAZARDOUS ASBESTOS FIBERS.
WERE STILL THE CRYSTAL HOME WHEN
THEY'RE CLOSE.
SB SIX FORTY FIVE IS ABOUT TRAIN
HUMANELY IN THEIR FINAL DAYS.
WHAT'S NOT HUMANE AS THE
UNNECESSARY STRESS OF ABUSE OF
DEPOSITIONS WHEN THESE VICTIMS
ARE STRUGGLING TO FIND JUSTICE
IN THE CIVIL COURT SYSTEM AND
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE THE ENTITIES
THAT BUT OTHER ILLNESSES.
DEPOSITIONS ARE STRESSFUL FOR
THOSE WHO ARE HEALTHY AND
EXPONENTIALLY MORE SO FOR THOSE
WHO ARE DYING [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY.
WE'VE SEEN DEPOSITIONS TAKE
HOURS.
UNLESS YOU PUT A LIMIT ON THE
TIME ALLOTTED FOR CASES WITH THE
PLAN IF WE WILL DIE WITHIN SIX
MONTHS [inaudible]
SB -- AS SB SIX FORTY FIVE DOES.
THE COOLEY CAN NEVER BE ENOUGH
TIME.
THE OPPOSED TO ARGUE ABOUT DUE
PROCESS THE TRUTH IS THAT THERE
IS ABSOLUTELY NO DENIAL OF DUE
PROCESS NO MATTER HOW MANY
DEFENDANTS THERE ON THE CASES.
BECAUSE OF THE VERY MOMENT THE
CASES FILED.
THERE'S A COMPLETE EXCHANGE OF
EVERY DOCUMENT REALLY RELEVANT
TO THE CASE IN EXISTENCE
EMPLOYMENT RECORDS SOCIAL
SECURITY RECORDS.
AND MEDICAL RECORDS.
THERE'S ALSO AN UNLIMITED NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS AT THE VICTIMS MUST
ANSWER IN WRITING FROM THE
DEFENDANT'S.
ABOUT EVERYTHING THEY MIGHT
REMEMBER.
AND THEY FILL OUT THE ANSWERS
WITH HELP.
FROM THE DOCUMENT A WORK HISTORY
SO THEY WILL MAKE FEWER MISTAKES
IN ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS IN
WRITING.
THEY WHEN THEY ARE IN THE LIVING
ROOM.
LOOK AT THE OXYGEN.
STRUGGLING TO BREATHE
[inaudible]
IN PAIN.
SURROUNDED BY DEFENSE ATTORNEYS.
AND THE LAST WEEKS OF THEIR
LIVES.
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY BE LEARN FOR
ANOTHER TEN HOURS A DEPOSITIONS?
WE BELIEVE NOTHING.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT THESE
VICTIMS CAN SAY IN THOSE
DEPOSITIONS THAT HASN'T ALREADY
BEEN ASKED IN THE UNLIMITED
AMOUNT OF QUESTIONS ANSWERED
BEFORE.
THE DEPOSITION ABOUT EVERY PLACE
THEY MIGHT HAVE BEEN EXPOSED AND
YOU EXPOSE THEM.
AND SHOULD SOMETHING UNFORESEEN
COME UP WITH THE INITIAL SEVEN
HOURS OF DEPOSITION TIME.
SOMETHING ANY THE CLARIFICATION.
MORE WRITTEN QUESTIONS CAN BE
ASKED.
AND THE JUDGE OVERSEEING THE
CASE CAN GRANT THREE MORE HOURS.
IT'S IMPORTANT REMEMBER THAT
SEVEN HOURS IS REALLY THREE OR
FOUR DAYS.
SINCE THESE VICTIMS CAN ONLY BE
DEPOSED FOR A LIMITED AMOUNT OF
TIME GIVEN THEIR DETERIORATING
CONDITION.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT TREATING
VICTIMS HE MAINLY DURING THE
FINAL DAYS I URGE YOUR I'VE OF
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION THINK WESTERMAN
KEITH DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT COUNCIL HIRE WORKERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
PROUD CO SPONSORS.
JUST REAL BRIEF LAST ONE OF I'M
SORRY WE'RE NOT CAN TAKE WORK
FOR THE TESTIMONY WERE JUST THAT
ASKING FOR SUPPORT I APPRECIATE
THAT I'LL JUST TELL YOU THAT
THIS IS THESE ARE HIGH IN
ADDITION TO TRADESMEN AND WOMEN
THERE ALSO HOSPICE.
THEY'VE GOT A PATIENTS THE THIS
BILL AFFECTS PATIENT THANK WILL
BE DEAD BY CHRISTMAS WAS NOT WE
NEED TO REMEMBER EITHER TAKE THE
MONEY WE'RE JUST TAKING SUPPORT
PLEASE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMISSION GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION MACHINISTS AND
UTILITY WORKERS UNION ON SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE WE'LL%
WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO HERE STRONG SUPPORT.
DANIEL TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MATT CRIMMINS ONLY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAN YOU DON'T YOU DROWNED WITH
THE CITY COUNCIL LABORS ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
MY CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS LAND TRITON
ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL WE THINK THE
AUTHOR AND WITNESSES AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FRIEND TRIBERG FOR THE
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
OF THE NATIONAL LAWYERS GUILD
AND WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEE NONE OPPOSITION
.
THIS RETURN MEMBERS MIKE BULLARD
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA DEFENSE
COUNSEL IN CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA --
WITH GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
EXTREMISTS POSITION THAT THESE
PLAINTIFFS ARE IN I HAD A GOOD
FRIEND DIED OF MESOTHELIOMA AND
IT WAS A HORRIBLE WAY TO GO.
THAT HAPPEN TO BE IDIOPATHIC
THEY COULD NOT TRACE IT TO ANY.
EXPOSURE TO ANYTHING BUT MOST ME
SO CASES ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS PAST US AND WE UNDERSTAND
IT.
AT THE SAME TIME.
DEFENDANTS DON'T DECIDE HOW MANY
DEFENDANTS ARE NAMED IN A CASE.
THAT DECISION IS MADE BY
PLAINTIFFS.
AND IT IS NOT UNCOMMON FOR THESE
CASES TO INVOLVE DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF DEFENDANTS.
BECAUSE THERE CAN BE MULTIPLE
AVENUES OF EXPOSURE YOU COULD
HAVE WORKED ON A SHIP.
THEN YOU COULD HAVE WORKED ON
YOUR OWN BREAKS AND DEALT WITH
THE IT'S BEST DOES CONTAINING
BRAKE PADS THEN YOU COULD HAVE
DONE HOME IMPROVEMENT WORK ON
YOUR OWN HOUSE.
THERE'S LOTS OF WAYS TO BE
EXPOSED TO ASBESTOS AND LOTS OF
DEFENDANTS ARE NAMED.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
SUBSTITUTES WHAT HAS BEEN
DESCRIBED AS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
CASE MANAGEMENT ORDER WHERE
JUDGES WHO DO THIS EVERY DAY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HAVE
UNIFORMLY SAID WE'RE GONNA START
WITH THE DEFAULT OF TWENTY HOURS.
IT CAN BE REDUCED OR INCREASED
AT THE MOTION OF THE PARTIES AND
WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE IT.
TO SEVEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE IN
A SPELL SPELLS LAWYER AND I'M
NOT. TO INTUITIVELY UNDERSTAND
THAT DEPOSITIONS ARE GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT IF THERE'S FIFTY
DEFENDANTS THAN IF THERE'S FIVE
THE QUESTIONS HAVE TO BE ASKED
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT A MOTION TO
DISMISS OR MOTION FOR SUMMARY
JUDGMENT.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT AT SEVEN
HOURS YOU HAVE AN ACTUAL DUE
PROCESS VIOLATION FOR DEFENDANTS.
BECAUSE THEY MAY WELL NOT GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS THEY NEED TO ASK. TO
SUPPORT THEIR MOTION FOR SUMMARY
JUDGMENT BY THE TIME THESE GET
TO TRIAL THERE ARE USUALLY NOT
FIFTY DEFENDANTS THERE ARE THREE
OR FOUR BECAUSE THIS PROCESS HAS
WEEDED OUT PEOPLE.
WHO DON'T BELONG IN THAT CASE?
WE HAVE MADE COMPROMISED OFFERS.
WHAT THE WITNESS AND?%
LORD I FEEL SORRY FOR HER
EXPERIENCE WITH HER FATHER.
BUT SHE ASKED FOR FOURTEEN THAT
IT BE LIMITED TO FOURTEEN HOURS
AND IRONICALLY THAT IS THE
COMPROMISE OFFER THAT WE MADE TO
GO TO WOULD DEFAULT PROVISION OF
FOURTEEN WE BELIEVE.
THAT THIS THING COULD BE
COMPROMISED AND A HUMANE RULE
ESTABLISHED THAT DOES TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE SHEER NUMBER OF
DEFENDANTS IN THESE CASES.
SO WE WOULD ASK THAT THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR CONTINUE T
NEGOTIATE WITH US SO THAT WE CAN
COME TO A FAIR MIDDLE GROUND ON
THIS.
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
OF SUPPLY.
MARK SEVEN WITH AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALLY INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEVEN TAYLOR WITH THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
ALL RIGHT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU SENATOR OF FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
AND TO THE THE WITNESS AS MY
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS AND PAIN YOU
SUFFERED -- AN IN.
WELL WHEN I WHEN I AND I BROOKS
DEFENSE ATTORNEY BUT IN CRIMINAL
LAW WHICH IS I KNOW VERY VERY
DIFFERENT.
BUT IN OFTENTIMES -- HIM WHETHER
WHETHER IT'S WORKPLACE HISTORY
WHAT HAVE YOU -- YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY TIME IN PLACE ISSUES
WHAT HAVE YOU THEIR OF THERE WAS.
TESTIMONY THAT WAS GARNERED IN
AND THE OTHER WAS STATEMENTS OR
NECESSARY FROM A NUMBER OF
WITNESSES.
I IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IN THESE
KINDS OF CASES THE PLAINTIFFS
THEMSELVES OF FOR THE MOST PART
THEY'RE NOT THE SCIENTISTS --
AND THEY MAY HAVE SOME
RECOLLECTION PRICE PUT OUT SOME
RECOLLECTION OF WHERE THEY WORK.
BUT BUT WHICH WOULD BE OF THE
THE PHYSICAL ENVIRONMENT IS
CRITICAL AYE AYE THE MAGIC OF
THESE KINDS OF CASES AS WELL AS
THE SCIENTIFIC -- OVER A BASIS
WHERE THE EXPERT TESTIMONY ON
BOTH SIDES WOULD COME IN AND I
EXPERT WITNESSES I KNOW PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN THESE TYPES OF
CASES.
BUT IT THE I GUESS THE QUESTION
OR THE COMMENT SLASH QUESTION IS
WHEN I WHEN I WOULD CAN GARNER
SOMEONE'S WORK HISTORY OF ME
WOULD USUALLY TAKE ME.
A MINUTE TWO MINUTES.
MAYBE FOR FIVE MINUTES WELL IT
WAS A CRITICAL.
ASPECT OF THE CASE.
AND I WOULD GET A BUSINESS
RECORDS INDICATING WHERE TEY
WORKED IT WAS US TRULY CRITICAL
ASPECT OF THE CASE PARTICULARLY
BUT HAVE TO DO WITH TIME
LOCATION REGARDING A PARTICULAR
ABOVE.
SUBURB OF TIME OF AN INCIDENT
AGAIN I UNDERSTAND IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT INCOME OVER TO CIVIL
AND I KNOW THAT ESPECIALLY
TALKING ABOUT.
SOMEONE IN A OF A DECADES OF
HISTORY WHETHER IT'S WORK
HISTORY OR AS THE OPPOSITION TO
CASE MAYBE THINGS AT HOME THAT
THEY MADE WORKED ON WHAT HAVE
YOU -- BUT IT BUT I GUESS --
THERE SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES IN EVIDENCE CODE
TO GET SOME OF THE KEY.
INFORMATION NECESSARY -- THAT A
PLAINTIFF BUT PERSONALLY HAVE --
AS OPPOSED TO WHERE YOU CAN GET
WHAT YOU CAN GET FROM.
RECORDS.
AND SO I I I I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS WHAT IS WHAT IS
TAKING ANOTHER NUMBER DEFENDANTS.
BUT I'VE BEEN IN MULTIPLE
DEFENDANT CASES WHERE A JUDGE
WILL.
LIMIT THE MATH TEST.
AT THE SAME THING THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN BOUGHT OUT BY TWO OR THREE
DEPENDENTS.
SO I I GUESS WHAT IS TAKING SO
MUCH TIME.
SO THAT I COULD -- I GUESS
THAT'S THE QUESTION TO GET TO A
WHAT IS TAKING SO MUCH TIME WHY
SO MUCH TIME NECESSARY AND I'M
HAPPY TO HEAR FROM BOTH SIDES
AND IN THAT REGARD.
WELL LET ME LEAD OFF.
OTHERS MAY WANT TO COMMENT ON
THAT AS WELL.
BUT AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
THIS I THINK.
WITHIN YOUR QUESTION.
THE ADVANCE DISCOVERY PRIOR TO
THE DEPOSITIONS BEING TAKEN.
IS VOLUMES OF INTERROGATORIES
AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY THE MORE
ACCURATE RECORD WHEN A PLAINTIFF
HAS TO RECONSTRUCT.
THE STREET ADDRESS OF THE
BUILDING HERE SHE WAS WORKING AT
FOR TWO WEEKS OR TWO MONTHS --
WHEN THEY'RE ON THEIR DEATH BED
IN YOU ASKED THE QUESTION THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN ANSWERED AN
INTERROGATORY THE GOAL OF THAT
QUESTION IN THE DEPOSITION IS TO
TRIP IT'S TO TRY TO GET THE
PLAINTIFF TO MAKE A MISTAKE?
IN THE STREET ADDRESS.
WHERE THE BUILDING LOCATION WAS
THAT BUILDING LOCATION?
IS THAT THE ONE YOU WORKED AT IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX OR WAS THAT THE
ONE YOU WORKED OUT IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN COM.
WITH THE ISSUE OF MULTIPLE
DEFENDANTS.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT PREVENTS
DEFENDANTS FROM COLLABORATING
AND COOPERATING THEY'RE
DEFENDING THEIR OWN INTEREST
OBVIOUSLY IN THEIR OWN CLIENT.
BUT THEY CAN ALSO WORK TOGETHER
TO PRIORITIZE -- AREAS OF
QUESTIONING IN IN DEPOSITION
THAT CAN BE HELPFUL. TO ALL OF
THEM ARE A GROUP OF THEM.
NOTHING PREVENTS THAT
COORDINATION IN BEING EFFICIENT
IN DEPOSITIONS.
BUT THE GROUND THAT'S BEING
COVERED IN TRYING.
WE HAVE CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE BROKEN THAT
ARE ALLOWING WHAT HAPPENED. TO
MISS BROUGHT MYERS FATHER ANA AN
ABSOLUTE ABUSE OF HUMAN RIGHTS I
BELIEVE TO TAKE SOMEBODY IN
THEIR FINAL DAYS OF LIFE.
AND AS WAS STATED BY HER FATHER
HIS GOAL WAS TO SURVIVE THE
DEPOSITION. TO PROTECT HIS
FAMILY IN HIS HONOR -- THERE'S
NOTHING SET MEMBERS SEVEN HOURS
TRANSLATES TO TWO OR THREE DAYS
OF CONVENING A DEPOSITION.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU.
GRANT SEVEN HOURS.
IT ALLOWS A JUDGE TO EXTEND IT
BY THREE HOURS WHICH COULD BE
ANOTHER DAY OR MAYBE TWO DAYS
EVEN DEPENDING.
ON HOW WEAK THE DEPONENT IS --
WE BELIEVE IT PROTECTS DUE
PROCESS.
AND REMEMBER THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO PROTECT.
THE DUE PROCESS.
IN HUMAN DIGNITY.
OF PLAINTIFFS IN THESE CASES.
OPPOSITION WAS ALSO LAST DAM --
THAT QUESTION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- YOU KNOW FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS I'VE LISTENED.
TO DEFENSE LAWYERS COMPLAIN
ABOUT PLAINTIFFS IN PLAINTIFFS
COMPLAIN ABOUT DEFENSE AND I IN
OUR AND I'M NOT.
HERE TO DEFEND HOW MS BROCK
MYERS FATHER WAS TREATED I DON'T
KNOW THE FACTS OF THAT.
I DO KNOW WHAT MY DEFENSE
LAWYERS SAY ABOUT THE UTILITY OF
INTERROGATORIES AND THEY TELL ME.
THAT THE INTERROGATIVE RESPONSE
TO INTERROGATORIES THEY GET IS
NOT HELPFUL.
IN MANY CASES THAT THEY ARE MERE
RECITATIONS OF WHAT WAS IN THE
COMPLAINT AND THEY DON'T GET
DOWN TO THE GRANULARITY.
AND REMEMBER ON IN ITS BEST DOES
CASE IT REALLY IS ALL ABOUT --
EXPOSURE IDENTIFICATION THERE'S
NO QUESTION OF CAUSATION THERE'S
NO QUESTION OF DAMAGE WEATHER
COULD BE QUESTIONS OF DAMAGES
BUT THERE'S REALLY NO QUESTION.
IF YOU ARE EXPOSED TO THE
PRODUCT AND YOU HAVE
MESOTHELIOMA YOU'RE GOING TO BE
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO BE LIABLE
SO IT'S ALL ABOUT EXPERTS WHOSE
PRODUCT YOU WERE EXPOSED.
TO AND WE ARE TOLD THAT THE
RESPONSES TO INTERROGATORIES.
ARE NOT HELPFUL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT'S YOUR QUESTION WHICH CAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THE STRESS.
I'M SORRY MR HOLDEN.
AND THE ADDRESS REALLY JUST
PICKING UP ON THE LAST QUESTION
WE WERE REALLY TO UNDERSTAND THE
YOU YOU SAID THAT THERE HAD BEEN
NEGOTIATIONS IRAQ I'M CLEAR ON
WHAT THE BILL IS SAYING IN TERMS
OF THE TIME FRAME JUST REMIND ME
WHAT IS.
THE PLACE THAT THE OPPOSITION IS
LANDING IN TERMS OF WHAT IS YOUR
VIEW OF THE COMPROMISE BECAUSE
I'M RIGHT.
I'M SURE IT'S BEEN SAID BUT IT'S
NOT CLEAR TO ME NOW AND LET ME
JUST ALSO SAY.
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS WHO.
IS IT THAT'S NOT DISPUTED THAT
THEY HAVE -- THIS ELEMENT RIGHT
AND THEY WORKED AROUND.
A PRODUCT THAT.
MORE THAN LIKELY WAS THE BECAUSE
HE SAID THAT THEY COULD HAVE
BEEN.
J. WORKING IN THE GARAGE OR
DOING SOME OTHER THINGS BUT I
THINK THAT -- THERE'S A LARGER
UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THE THE NATURE OF THEIR JOB OR
WHAT THEY WERE WORKING AROUND AS
BEST AS WAS MORE THAN LIKELY THE
COSTS OF NOW.
THE LAWSUITS BEEN FILED WE'RE
GOING THROUGH THIS PROCESS THE
AUTHOR HAS A AND THE WITNESS
HAVE MADE WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER
PRETTY COMPELLING ARGUMENT.
THAT -- THE THE PROCESS OF
GETTING.
TO THE GRANULARITY OF THE ISSUE
IS KIND OF RUNNING OUT THE CLOCK
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE AT THE END
OF LIFE.
AND SO.
WE'RE DOWN TO A PLACE WHERE --
THE BILL SAYS SEVEN HOURS.
WHICH TRANSLATES INTO.
A NUMBER OF DAYS -- THE JUDGE
HAS THE RIGHT TO EXTEND IT. FOR
A PERIOD OF TIME AND WHAT IS IT
THAT YOU'RE SEEING IS.
NOT ENOUGH TIME IN THAT -- AS
BEEN DESCRIBED TO FOR EVERYONE
TO GET TO THE PLACE OF THE TRUTH.
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
OF THIS ROLE IN THANKS -- THE
OFFER THAT WE MADE TWO YEARS AGO
WAS A DEFAULT OF FOURTEEN HOURS
INSTEAD OF TWENTY WHICH WAS THE
AMOUNT THAT APPARENTLY OF THE
LAWYERS IN THIS CASE ASK -- FOR
WITH THE ABILITY OF THE
PLAINTIFF TO MOVE FOR LESS TIME
AND THE DEFENSE TO MOVE FOR MORE.
A WE WERE TOLD THAT THE CONCERN
WAS TE REIMPOSITION OF THE CASE
MANAGEMENT ORDER WHICH WOULD
RENDER THE BILL OR LAW MOOT --
SO WE SAID NO -- YOU COULDN'T
USE A CASE MANAGEMENT ORDERED A
VERY IT HE WOULD HAVE TO
INDIVIDUALLY EVALUATE EACH CASE --
THERE HAS BEEN A CONCERN THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL EVALUATION IS NOT
OCCURRING AND WE WOULD DO WHAT
WE COULD IN THE BILL.
TO REQUIRE THAT.
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS A FAIR
COMPROMISE OF COURSE THAT'S NOT
MY CALL THAT'S YOURS.
BUT I THOUGHT A REDUCTION FROM
TWENTY TO FOURTEEN WAS A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL REDUCTION AND THAT
WOULD BE THE DEFAULT.
OTHERS HAVE SUGGESTED YOU COULD
HAVE SOME SORT OF SLIDING SCALE
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
DEFENDANTS AGAIN WE DON'T CHOOSE
WE MAY BE DEFENDED.
SIXTY TWO AND SO MAYBE YOU HAVE
SOME MINIMUM AMOUNT PER
DEFENDANT.
WE ARE WILLING TO TALK ABOUT ALL
OF THOSE THINGS -- BEFORE GIVEN
THE CHANCE.
AND IF I MIGHT THROUGH THE CHAIR
RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION AS WELL.
YEAH IF THE THIS QUESTION WAS
FOR BOTH YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
ON I WOULD REMIND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THAT.
THE BILL THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
LAST YEAR WAS SEVEN HOURS PLUS.
SEVEN FOURTEEN HOURS THAT WAS
OPPOSED BY THE PEOPLE HERE
PROPOSING.
THAT AMENDMENT NOW I WOULD ASK
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
IF THE OPPOSITION WOULD CONSIDER
REMOVING ANA WOULD PAY PAIN AND
SUFFERING EVEN IF THE PLAINTIFF
DIES.
DURING THE DEPOSITION WITH DATE
WELCOME AN AMENDMENT THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE FAMILY TOOK ROOT
RECOVER FOR PAIN AND SUFFERING
WHICH THEY'RE CURRENTLY.
DENIED WELL IT CHEN FOR NOT
GOING TO NEGOTIATE.
THINGS THAT ARE NOT IN FRONT OF
US OR REALLY TO GO TO THE TERMS
OF THE BILL THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING FROM.
OUR STATE FOR THE COMMITTEE
STANDPOINT THE QUESTION.
DOES THIS BILL DESERVE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AS IT IS KNOWING THAT THERE MAY
BE.
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS AND
SOMETIMES COMMITTEE MEMBERS TAKE
THOSE.
ACT INTO ACCOUNT AS THEY'RE
DECIDING ON A BILL FROM MY
STANDPOINT IF YOU READ THE
ANALYSIS I THINK WE'RE VERY
CLEAR.
GIVEN.
THE INTERACTIONS GIVEN THE
REALITIES OF THE SITUATION THAT
SETTING A STANDARD THAT YOU'VE
REQUESTED SENATOR IS. TO ME
MEETS THE THE STANDARDS HERE FOR
THIS COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE THIS BILL.
THAT'S REALLY THE QUESTION
BEFORE US.
ANYTHING BEYOND THAT IS
CERTAINLY UP TO YOU AND YOU CAN
ENTERTAIN THAT BUT ANY BILL THAT
GOES OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE IF IT
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED AND DOES
NOT MEET THE STANDARDS COMMITTEE
MAY ALSO BE.
DRAWN BACK IN THANK YOU.
THERE ARE SERBS HOLD YOUR FOLLOW
UP.
JUST TO TIE UP MY POSITION ON IT
I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL -- I
WOULD ENCOURAGE.
THAT KIND OF A CONVERSATION TO
CONTINUE -- IT DOESN'T -- IMPACT
ON MY WILLINGNESS TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY -- AND QUITE FRANKLY MAY
NOT IMPACT ON MY WILLINGNESS TO
VOTE ON IT ON THE FLOOR BUT IT
WOULD BE -- GOOD TO KNOW THAT
THEIR SORT OF EFFORT TO TRY TO
RECONCILE WHAT APPEARS TO BE.
MAYBE FOUR HOURS -- AND SOME
OTHER CONDITIONS AROUND THE
SMALL THANK YOU THANKS.
SERVICE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THE IT'S CLEAR THAT THIS IS ONLY
FOR THOSE WHO ARE TERMINALLY ILL.
WHO HAVE SIX MONTHS TO LIVE --
THIS IS AFTER INTERROGATORIES
AND THERE CAN BE A REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL INTERROGATORIES SO
THAT THIS IS DONE WITH THE HELP
OF THE LAWYERS AND WITH IT --
AND IT IT'S ALWAYS VERY HELPFUL
WHEN THEY'RE UNION RECORDS.
AND SO YOU KNOW THIS IS THE ONE
TIME WHEN IT'S THE BEST IF YOU
HAVE YOUR UNION YOU BEEN WORKING
THROUGH THROUGH THE UNION.
THE UNION IS ABLE TO PROVIDE --
ALL OF THE RECORD SO THAT IT'S
MUCH EASIER TO PRESENT THE CASE --
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM COURSES THE
LATENCY PERIOD BETWEEN THE TIME
YOU EXPOSED IN THE TIME.
THE CHIU FINALLY ARE AT THE
POINT WHERE YOU HAVE TO PRESENT
THE THE THE LAWSUIT -- THE THE
ONLY COMMENT THAT WAS MADE IN
THE IN THE EIGHT ANALYSIS.
ON PAGE.
SEVEN THERE'S NO QUESTION I WAS
SUPPORT THIS IT'S I IS AN
ATTORNEY A IN WORKERS COMP I HAD
TO BE INVOLVED IN THESE.
CASES WHERE.
DEPOSITIONS WERE TAKEN AND AT
ONE DEFENSE COUNSEL.
AFTER CASES FINALLY SETTLED TELL
ME THEY WERE -- HOPING MY CLIENT
WOULD DIE IT WOULD.
MAKE IT MUCH EASIER NOT THAT
THEY WERE HOPING MICHAEL I WOULD
DIE THAT THEY WERE EXPECTING HE
WOULD PROBABLY DIE AND THEN IT
WOULD CHANGE EVERYTHING.
THE COMMENTS REGARDING DUE
PROCESS IN MAKING SURE THE
DEFENDANTS TO HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY. TO TO BECAUSE EACH
ONE FOR EACH ONE IS DEFENDING
THEIR OWN CLIENT.
THEY WANT TO GET THEIR CLIENT
OUT OF THAT LAWSUIT.
AND IT BECOMES A QUESTION OF DUE
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHOEVER DOESN'T BELONG TO THE
LAWSUIT GETS TAKEN OUT -- AND
THE ONLY WAY THAT'S GOING TO BE
DONE IS TO DISCOVERY WEATHER'S
INTERROGATORIES OR DEPOSITIONS --
THE COMMENT MADE IN THE ANALYSIS
WAS.
THAT AS THE BILL ADVANCES THAT
TO THE AUTHOR SUPPORTERS MAY
WISH TO ENGAGE -- WITH THE
OPPONENTS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THERE IS A MIDDLE GROUND.
THAT WOULD BE THE ONLY THING
THAT I WOULD -- SUGGEST -- AS
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS -- BUT
THERE SHOULD BE.
THERE THERE SHOULD BE A PERIOD.
AT THE END OF THE SENTENCE THERE
SHOULD BE A A A DETERMINATE --
NUMBER OF HOURS THE SHOULD BE
USED FOR FOR DISCOVERY
ESPECIALLY WHEN A PERSON IS.
AT THE END BUT I WOULD ASK THAT
AS NOTED ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS.
THAT YOU MAY WANT TO CONTINUE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU AND FOR THE RECORD OUR
DOOR HAS BEEN OPENED THROUGHOUT.
WE HAVE HIT -- IN PAST IN THE
PAST -- WHERE THERE WAS
OPPOSITION? FOR SEVEN PLUS.
SEVEN WE BELIEVE IF I COULD JUST
THROUGH THE CHAIR COME IN ON THE
DUE PROCESS ISSUE.
THAT -- WITH THAT THERE WAS THAT
ACTUALLY QUESTION THERE IS DID
YOU MISS REYES MENTOR.
ASK A QUESTION ABOUT THE DUE
PROCESS ISSUE -- I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR SENATOR MUNNINGS --
COMMENTS REGARDING DUE PROCESS
IF HE HAS.
AS I THINK IT'S IT'S THE
STRONGEST ARGUMENT.
OF DEFENDANTS COUNSEL IS SOMEHOW
BEING DENIED DUE PROCESS -- BUT
FOR SOME OF THE REASONS YOU
CITED AND FOR REASONS CITED
EARLIER.
THE CASE MANAGEMENT IN THESE
CASES INVOLVES YOU DON'T HAVE TO
FIGHT TO GET CERTAIN RECORDS
BECAUSE IT'S MANDATED.
THAT EMPLOYMENT RECORDS OTHER%
MEDICAL RECORDS THEY'RE ALL
EXCHANGED READ AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE CASE.
SO IS INTERROGATORIES ARE
DEVELOPED THEY CAN DRAW FROM
THAT PRELIMINARY EXCHANGE OF
INFORMATION YOU'RE NOT FIGHTING
TO GET MEDICAL RECORDS YOU'RE
NOT FIGHTING TO GET EMPLOYMENT
RECORDS.
INTERROGATORIES FURTHER REFINE
ON THAT EARLY INFORMATION
EXCHANGE.
THE PURPOSE OF DEPOSITION IS TO
MAYBE CLARIFY WHAT IS NOT FULLY
ANSWERED IN AN INTERROGATORY OR
WHERE THERE'S A LACK OF CLARITY --
BUT WHAT WE SEE IN THESE CASES
IS AN INCENTIVE. TO ASK EVERY
QUESTION IT'S LISTED IN AN
INTERROGATORY FOR THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF RUNNING OUT THE TIME
RUNNING OUT THE CLOCK.
THERE'S A BUILT IN INCENTIVE TO
PROTRACTED THE DEPOSITIONS.
IT'S A FAULT IN THE LAW I
BELIEVE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
LIMITED UNIVERSE OF TERMINALLY
ILL DYING PATIENTS FOR WHOM WERE
TRYING TO STRIKE A BALANCE.
THAT I BELIEVE PROTECTS THE DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS OF NOT ONLY THE
DEFENDANT'S.
BUT ALSO OF THE PLAINTIFF TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN THE DUE PROCESS IN THAT
LAWSUIT.
WELL HAVING THE HUMAN DIGNITY
AND RESPECT NOT TO HAVE TO BE
QUESTIONED.
IN THEIR DYING HOURS
[inaudible]
ADDRESS.
IT APPEARS THEM THAT -- ONCE THE
SIGNED BY BY GOVERNOR NEWSOME.
THEN THERE WOULD BE A SHIFTING
OF MORE ORGANIZATIONAL SIDE OF
THE DEFENSE. TO HAVE A LEAD
DEFENSE PERHAPS -- BUT AGAIN
GOING BACK TO JUST THAT ONE
SENTENCE IN THE ANALYSIS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU AS
CHAIR OF THE CHAU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP.
ALL I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY ARE YET I WOULD LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE BOTH SIDES TO
CONTINUE NEGOTIATING AND
COMMUNICATING -- I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENTS RAISED
BY THE BOTH SIDES ON THE ONE
HAND ARE THESE DEPOSITIONS COULD
INDEED BE DEVASTATING.
TO A WITNESS ARE AND HIS DEATH
BED.
AND OP ON THE OTHER HAND I I I I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THE DEFICIENCIES
OF SOME OF THESE IN WRITTEN
INTERROGATORIES AS WELL AS TO
TACTIC TO OUR STRATEGIES EMPLOY.
ACCOUNTABLE BY SOME COUNCIL.
YET I THINK BOB.
IN CASES WHERE YOU HAVE MULTIPLE
DEFENDANTS I THINK EACH ONE OF
THEM.
OUGHT TO BE GIVEN.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DEFEND HIMSELF
OR HERSELF -- ITSELF -- SAID
THAT THE YOU KNOW THE THE
PROCESS COULD BE COMPLETED.
SO WHICH IS THE REASON WHY I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE SHOP BOTH
SIDES TO CONTINUE.
ARE COMMUNICATING AND I THINK IT
SOUNDED LIKE THERE MIGHT BE SOME
ROOM ON BY IN NOT REACHING A
COMPROMISE SO.
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO
THAT AND I ALSO FINALLY ONE
THINK THE WIND IS FOR BEING HERE
TODAY FOR SHARING.
YOUR STORY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS ALL RIGHT
SEE NONE CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR IN YOUR STAFF AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE IN OBVIOUS CARE
ATTENTION. TO WHAT'S A VERY
SERIOUS QUESTION BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AND BEFORE OUR STATE.
I WOULD URGE YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY --
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
UNDER THE STATUS QUO --
DEFENDANTS ARE INCENTIVIZED TO
RUN OUT THE CLOCK.
SO TO SPEAK THAT IN OUR PRIOR
NEGOTIATION EFFORTS AND I COMMIT
WERE CONTINUE OR COMMITTED.
TO LOOKING FOR COMPROMISE BUT AS
I POINTED OUT -- THE BILL THAT
WAS PUT UP LAST YEAR WAS OPPOSED --
TO ENDS.
THAT WAS NOT ADEQUATE. TO MEET
WHAT WE'RE NOW TOLD IS A
LEGITIMATE COMPROMISED SO WE'RE
PREPARED TO CONTINUE WORKING ON
IT.
I WOULD JUST FINALLY CLOSE BY
SAYING WE ARE TRYING TO FIND A
BALANCE IN A LIMITED UNIVERSE OF
CASES.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
PROBABLY IN THE AREA OF A
HUNDRED WE'RE NOT TALKING
THOUSANDS OF CASES.
AS ONE OF THE WITNESSES STATED.
PEOPLE TODAY WHO HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH MESOTHELIOMA OR
SILICOSIS.
THEY WILL BE DEAD BY CHRISTMAS.
THIS BILL WILL NOT PROTECT THEM.
S. DEPOSITIONS ARE DRAGGED OUT
UP TO THEIR POINT OF DEATH
REWARDING.
THE DEFENDANTS IF THEY DIE
BEFORE THE CASE IS CONCLUDED.
MEMBERS YOU'VE HEARD COMPELLING
TESTIMONY -- FROM THE DAUGHTER
OF A VICTIM.
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE HORRIFIC
NATURE.
OF THIS DISEASE [inaudible]
THAT IS.
ADMITTED TO BE CAUSED BY
EXPOSURE.
WE THINK WE'VE STRUCK THE
BALANCE THAT PROTECTS THE DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS OF DEFENDANTS
WERE PROTECTING.
THE DIGNITY OF THE PLAINTIFFS I
WOULD URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND MOTION IS DO
PASS CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE
BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHU CHU AYE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE FONG [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
CHIU NORRIS IRATE S..
REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER THERE
THANK YOU EMBERS CONCLUDES THE
PRESENTATIONS ON BILLS LET'S GO
BACK THROUGH THE LIST ANYONE WHO
HAS MISSED A VOTE.
MAY.
ADD ONS WILL START WITH CONSENT
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS CHAO.
CHAO I'D.
TO CHIU AYE PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
CONSENT [inaudible]
NORTH SIDE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS SB THIRTY
SENATOR WINNER OF THE OF THE
MEMBERS CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
AND SALAS AYE.
I TO RIVER TO SB FORTY ONE
HERTZBERG. TWO CHU I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT MITCHELL CHU.
CHU AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB TWO TWENTY
FIVE THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SP FOUR NINETY
FIVE DORADO.
CHAO [inaudible]
I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETER NORTH SIDE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FIVE FORTY
FOR A BURKE.
CHAU.
CHAO AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I SB SIX FORTY
FIVE I BELIEVE WE HAVE.
EVERYONE S. IS ITEMS EIGHT SB
SIX EIGHTY WHITE HOUSE KING CHU.
CHU AYE.
AND ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB SIX
THIRTY EASTERN CHOW.
CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I I DON'T KNOW IF
HE MAIENSCHEIN.
HE IS OKAY DRUGS SO HE'S GONE
YEAH HE'S [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED